[Music]
[Music]
three
two one
[Music]
three two one
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
get out take it out
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
better
[Music]
okay
[Music]
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
there
there's
[Music]
there's
[Music]
this would be stalemate if i don't do
this
okay sure sure
xqcl
but i can play queen c8 this is a
ridiculous move
where i still stayed defending my rook
your queen now is under attack
and your rook is also under attack and
you can't defend everything oh
wait what if i did this
[Music]
oh you're trying to get here
yeah how do you handle that threat
unfortunately there's this
with check oh there's check
check i forgot the queen can go
that way thank you
that's my queen no
oh i blundered i'm blending bad
oh he gave me it back thank you so much
okay okay he let me undo oh thank you
okay okay
no that's my queen yes
i've got one idea only one idea that'll
be so
[ __ ] good please don't mess this up
all i need to do is move the point up
here
he'll be trapped yes he's trapped
please tell me is please please
please please please please has you got
anything can you do anything
can you do anything
[Applause]
[Music]
yes taking d5 to d6 takes
d5 takes e6 so put the d5 on e6
and you will see that magic happens yes
i've never
wow that was a mind that's like a glitch
was that but i'm terrible at this game
i'm really so bad
i'm so bad that was so embarrassing in
so many ways he wants a rematch
get out of here
[Music]
holy sh come here dude
oh my god he is so whole oh my god
[Music]
oh i had checkmate i got so scared wait
wait
no don't stop everybody stop shut up
shut up
shut up stop
stop oh
oh one second i just got disconnected
give me one second chance
it's our chance to eat everything
it's actually working go back
sorry oh janet
chad come see me in my office
it's fine okay we can recover from this
you were i saw clips of you
talking trash non-stop before the game
okay and then also
says the one that streams like my
streamer says when i was sitting in my
chat
watching my tactics sent me a clip
someone sent me a clip
okay that's not sitting in your stream
no
you were in my streams specifically more
than one hour okay
we have to use in the chat you stream
sniped my tactics
i use shadowy i for starters i use
chaturino and secondly slicker
if you want to watch me play chess in my
channel twitch tv slash name you're
welcome to do so maybe you'll learn a
thing or two
well okay let me tell you so let me tell
you something listen let me tell you
these
everyone this guy is a joke let me tell
you right now a simple joke
why think what you're doing think nim
okay go back to being a dj my friend
because you don't know who you're
messing around with
well i mean i think more than that for
me it's not it's not so much about
guessing it's the fact that
oh oh oh my gosh
here comes the oh like this here comes
the owl
oh
my god listen name if you're watching
do you guys swear is this piggy three
are you allowed to swear in this
interview
um i mean preferably not but
you don't really nim you are a pile of
rubbish you are gonna lose me if you're
watching this you're gonna lose
you're gonna absolutely get destroyed
trust me and we are live we're joined by
ludwig and boxbox ludwig do you want to
ask
the question you you just did before we
were on yeah alex um my questions why
did you
yeah from weaponized sex toys to chess
drama
seems like the natural progression there
i think i think everyone would really be
surprised if you take nothing else away
from today i think the thing to take
away is just
how versatile sex toys can truly be like
there's so much more to them
than they get credit taking an object
like a flashlight a rubber vagina
and seeing it in a different way as long
as you make sure that the opponent's
king has squares or if it doesn't
you're checking it that's the way to go
for it
here you go it's the world's smallest
violin
playing just
[Music]
i told
[Music]
i have to join an interview okay see you
later see ya peter thank you
hello oh sorry not yet
son of a son of a
no you just have to move your piece
unless you can take so then he's going
to grab me
god damn it
[Music]
i'm gonna waste time here this is what
you get for this mate i'm gonna waste
time
two minutes i waste my time let me blast
some two bags
ignores what i suggested which is
completely fine if this is what he
prepared oh
oh you think he prepared this he likes
gambits
oh wow oh wow so ludwig decides to play
the
latvian gambit um now we'll see right
away if ludwig did some preparation here
yeah let's let's take a listen into his
stream to see what he's saying
yeah sure he said he doesn't have time
to teach
me he said ludwig okay uh teach a lot
about wow
i could teach a lot of uh uh well uh
what what's xqc up to
apparently my viewer count the latvian
gambit advice
so his one piece of advice
being gambit but now what do i do now
what
am i supposed to do hikaru this is not
what i told you
at all um
the process here because when you bring
out the bishop like this
uh it can become very vulnerable right
away so i'm not sure that i like the
like the variational approach here
no please don't and it's too soon
it's too soon hikaru we didn't even
reach a climax
like this isn't really defending
anything except this piece she she
uh he could take this but i could take
this um
i'ma just do this wait what what was
that the move wait i can't move his
piece
what was i gonna do what was it gonna do
oh my god what was it gonna do what was
my move oh no
it was my move what was my move
wait was i thinking about doing this
because i can't oh i'm gonna go like
this
oh no she's doing that box box was
playing his master promo not he's not
quite challenger but he's
he's on his way um i'm not either right
now you know leaves a struggle sometimes
but anyway
so i i i beat him i hard carry against
him in the game he needed to win for his
master promo
as a as a good friend you would think oh
like i would go easy on him like maybe
you know give him a chance no no
he needs to earn that and just like he
needs to earn this chess pog champs
championship and he wants to meet me
in the next round or whatever like you
know albert zang bring it on
but i destroyed him in the master promo
and i'm gonna fudging destroy him in the
chess match
i hope you spend 50 hours studying my
openings and analyzing my games and get
coached by hikaru
alexander danny and magnus carlson
because no matter what you do box box
i will destroy you you're going to be
one box
smashed into a little cube and i'm gonna
checkmate that ass
so easily so
you know when i said it'd be fun to see
a checkmate in four earlier i was i was
joking it was
i it wasn't real
we're listening to moist critical right
now daniel naraditsky
is a prophet he said immediately
that xqc will likely go with the scotch
open
and he did so i had the counter play and
he immediately blundered
well that's got to be a world record my
is throbbing okay
every game that it makes that far i
won't go that far okay i won't go that
far listen hearthstone stick to
hearthstone
okay listen you stick to playing mage or
whatever the other champions are
that's you're just 2d andy that's what
you are foreskin i mean um
forsen okay starcraft is quiet the
complicated again
well i mean it's stuck i feel like i'll
play starcraft
are you 50 years old are you the
tomorrow's age no
oh my god look at that okay i actually
have to oh my god
it's on the board it's on the board of
god
oh my god
[Music]
she only saw that it was a chat she
didn't see the queen
she's a queen i am a freaking
genius
why'd you give your bishop for free
though come on little you had 500 gifted
subs on the line you cannot
be living life with that kind of risk
alex alex
here's a little thing that i'm going to
pass on to from one streamer to another
it's
called throwing for content you got to
make it a little more exciting
all right throwing a hanging bishop have
everybody in suspense for a moment
my end game's phenomenal you know why i
pick up the vorkshki's endgame book
okay now i can't read a [ __ ] word of
this because it's all in chess notation
it makes no sense but i own it
and this alone has been a 300 point up
for me
um have you been like sleeping next to
it trying to get some you know awesome
every night i no longer own a pillow i
just sleep on dvorsky's book
fourth edition all right so we're going
to be watching this
chess match here guys um it's between
moist critical and xqc
well i guess that's the end of the chess
match between moist critical and xqc
another riveting bout between those two
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
one two three
oh my god
there's more oh my god this is insane
[Applause]
yeah baby that's what i've been waiting
for that's what it's all about
magic time
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back with the final day of
pogchamps three presented by grip six
hey caro
we did it another amazing pogchamps
event is about to be
in the books how excited are you for
championship sunday
uh really excited i think both matchups
today are going to be really really
close i think this match between sardosh
and rayne wilson two of the early
favorites in the championship bracket
um i think it's anyone's game and then
there's a match between nico and
michelle care
uh also i think it's very hard to have
predicted that that either of them would
have reached the final i'm in the
consolation brackets so all the players
who are here they deserve to be
be here they've played very well
throughout and it's going to be really
really exciting
we're going to have a fun day here as we
bring it to a close regardless of who
wins
let's remind everybody who's already
been here for a while i hope you enjoyed
that season one
highlights video to remind you of where
it all began but let's
bring everybody's attention to the
format and remind them of what's in
store
as zaccaro said we're in the bracket
stage it's single elimination which
always hurts at this stage
it's not as fun almost in some way
zacaro as the early group stage because
we know that
we might be watching someone's last
match in every moment right because you
know it's win or go home
but it's still a blast and obviously
yesterday and the day before we had
matches go to tiebreaker so will it
happen again today
if it does it's only five minutes with a
zero second increment
uh to uh to decide who who moves on or
in this case
actually wins their particular bracket
uh and then of course
the uh as we said it's two brackets as a
car already noted
we have consolation and championship the
prizes
that are up for the individual players
are what you see before you it's a
hundred thousand dollars in guaranteed
cash
that goes directly to the players for
them to spend however they want i know
players
like rayne wilson intend for all of what
they earn here probably to go to charity
but i know that for a lot of streamers
too this is a really big payday it's a
huge chess tournament
and a lot of money on the line and
speaking of what goes to charity
just.com came into this event with the
intent to spend a hundred thousand
dollars on top of the 100 000
prize fund and so today announcing right
now we are doubling
the match of the community which means
you the community
have already raised more than 75 000
and if you help us reach that fifty
thousand dollar mark it will mean a
hundred thousand dollars cash out of
chess.com's pocket so
we're hopeful to get there but no matter
what happens on sunday we know
the community you've already done such
an amazing job you've been super
generous
but we're hoping to spend all hundred
thousand dollars of our money
and we hope that you help us get there
by reaching that fifty thousand dollar
mark
all right hicaro let's talk a little bit
about these particular match-ups nico
versus michelle carrey as you said
neither player maybe was expected to get
there but maybe in hindsight we should
have seen it coming
either way it's definitely two players
with very opposite styles
yeah certainly i think one of the things
that emerged from pogchamps too is we
had hafu who ended up winning the whole
event she won the champions bracket
and ever since she started grinding
every day there have been like people
who have been comparing
um some of the players who have been
trying to study like her and i think two
of the players in the finals on both
sides championship and in the
constellation and
sardosh and michelle kari have kind of
sort of done the mini hafu or the full
hawfu
um especially in saradosh's case where
it seems like he's playing chess 23
hours a day
um but in terms of michelle she also has
been grinding every day doing just a few
hours and so her progress
i think from the group stage winning
winning two matches i think she had to
play both her quarters and semis on the
same day against mr beast
and pokeyman and now playing here in the
final today um she's been doing an
amazing job
so uh both of them are looking good i
think i'm
actually going to go out on a limb and
predict that that michelle is going to
win and i think sardosh is going to win
as well
okay well there you go and i you know
i'll echo what you said that michelle um
okay a lot of players have improved a
ton so i hope anyone listening doesn't
take that the wrong way but i think an
argument can be made that michelle might
have improved the most of
anyone as far as where she came kind of
just learning the rules of the game
to where she is now so that's been just
inspiring to see and of course we can't
wait to see
uh whatever that uh video kind of
documentary looks like as far as her
journey and what her experience was in
pogchamps and with the chess community
um and yeah i don't think you're uh
you're crazy to be predicting sardosh at
all
um obviously i've been working with
rayne for on and off for a few years now
and certainly he
came into this event to have fun and
it's gotten more serious for him as he's
proven to himself
maybe he has a chance but but i think
sardo's i mean i i can kind of explain
i can kind of explain why i think
sardosh is a clear favorite because i
was thinking about this last night and
um
i think when i look at sardosh in the
games that he lost the games they lost
to benjamin in the game that he also
lost ludwig
neither of those players really made
many major mistakes there were mistakes
made by benji and ludwig in those games
but they played a pretty good game from
start to finish at five like and when i
think about reigns progress
he's played very very well but when he
hasn't gotten a big advantage at the
very start of the game
he has not put together a complete game
so that's that's the the single biggest
reason i think sardosh is very likely to
win
is i feel like rain at critical moments
has made some mistakes um
in some of the some of the matchups i
think against sardos
making mistakes of the nature that he's
made in some of these earlier matches
will be
will be insurmountable totally fair and
also i think you and i have talked a lot
about it for some reason you and i have
had several
uh sardosh matches he just seems to be
best in fast time control right and so
another reason why it's kind of hard
to pick against the the hard-working
frenchman is because of just how well
he's carried himself in those
most critical moments and by the way
unity just rolling in right now
thank you so much again remember we are
doubling our previous
double i don't know how to say that but
no matter what you see on the screen
it's it's double more than that so if we
reach 50 000 it will mean a hundred
thousand dollars from chess.com so thank
you so much throughout the day if we get
there
also before we take our first break and
come back with the starts of the matches
thank you again
to our sponsors uh guyaki
is supporting dog champs with their
donation and with cases of your favorite
regenerative yerba mate
they're celebrating 25 years and they're
sharing the love to prove it
of course we really appreciate their
support and any subscriber to the chess
channel
can win multiple cases of gaia ki or
yerba mate if you spam the emote
right now you know the drill you've
subscribed for a while some of you are
going to be winning
your romantic cases can't wait for it
and thank you so much already for the
community support don't go anywhere
when hikaro and i come back it's
championship sunday
it's nico versus michelle correa
consolation bracket finals
with pogchamps 3 presented by grip 6
returns the regeneration of the planet
is integrated into our business model
purchases of guayaqui
yerba mate support stewardship of the
south american atlantic rainforest
and the self-sufficiency of indigenous
communities
these purchases advance a
carbon-balanced renewable energy economy
and provide meaningful employment for
the formerly incarcerated
guayaqui's sales also fuel communities
and activists
driving the regenerative movement
meanwhile
your enjoyment of yerba mate reconnects
you with the vitality of
life when we come to life we care about
one another
and stand together to create a better
[Music]
future
[Music]
what's your username bishop
i've say clg c-o-g
so who wants to play
oh you're a little too low bro anybody
above 900 so around 900 who's 900.
[Music]
yo any 900ers hey chess tv what's up
we're currently doing sub battles
we're trying to find somebody who is 900
rated to play in the sub battle
any 900 we just need
one 900 rated dude just one
one sub what's your use today you're
here
why can't i not start your game
you have to go to live chess buddy go to
live chess right now
i know where they last i know where they
last
but it's fine because we lost in sub
battles today
[Music]
we're going to win in lcs right guys
that's how karma works
because we lost in sub battles at cog
cog's gonna pop the [ __ ] up
in lscs today right right
you're in live chess is your username
correct
we're we're gonna win tonight we're
gonna win tonight don't even sweat it
don't even sweat it we are go who are we
playing tonight actually
oh we're playing dignitas ah
they're only the second place team in
the lcs right now
yeah this is gonna be a win for sure hey
frick crazy thank you for the two one
no but honestly cog has been getting
first bloods
11 out of 11 games like we will win
tonight
we will okay
pinky promise we're gonna win tonight
right chat
don't even worry don't even worry okay
we also
i mean this is actually over but maybe
maybe if we
win the next two games i can ask alireza
if he wants to play me in a game and
we'll see how that goes
no no we're going to win tonight gootax
we're going to win i think we have a
very good chance to win
not only in this game
actually it doesn't really matter if we
win anymore here but i want cog to win
cog can win tonight okay
okay we got this
[Music]
uh
and welcome back to pogchamps 3
presented by grip6 it's
championship sunday and before the
championship matchup the consolation
bracket occurs
we have both niko and michelle carrey
here to talk a little bit
about the charities they chose um with
all the support raining in here we can't
wait to hear from these ladies to tell
us
a little bit about why they chose their
charity what it means to them and so
nico
over to you first the charity you chose
is unicef tell us why you chose that
charity
and um any anything that it means to you
and
and all that stuff um
so i was very in a hurry to pick a
charity and i was just there's like so
many causes i care about
but i feel like above like all of them i
think
one of something i really do care about
is like the humanitarian work
and i feel like unicef provides
all that across like the world and i was
like well that blankets like
everywhere you know not just specific a
specific region
so that's kind of like what i chose you
know that everyone has
uh at least like the necessities and
that's really important to me
that makes a lot of sense michelle you
chose face
africa uh tell us a little bit about
that charity and what your connection is
to them and what you
what you like about what what the work
the work is that they do
yeah absolutely so face africa is a
really
amazing organization that builds water
wells in africa for communities that do
not have running water
most of the water fetching
responsibilities usually fall on
women in the communities and because
women end up spending so much time
walking back and forth from the water
sources which can oftentimes be several
miles away from their home
it prohibits them from spending as much
time in school
or advancing and other educational
aspects so they do a lot of amazing work
and when they install the well they
actually do a full community project to
educate the community on how to upkeep
the well
and sort of build an economy around it
and also
do a lot of sexual health education for
the women in the men
and i just think it's really amazing
i've worked with them a few times and
i would love to contribute again to
their cause especially because they're
doing
so much wonderful relief there or covid
as well wow amazing
just made it impossible for me and
hicario to root for either of you both
those charities sound awesome hey cara
which i'm just kidding
pretend that they're not here which
charity are you rooting for
mean i i don't have one to pick but i
will say that i haven't spent i spent
some time um
in in africa i was inside i've been in
south africa i've been i was in libya
many years ago
so um so i i have seen some of the some
of the everyday struggles um
in africa and i i think it's it's a
great cause so i'll just leave it there
but both are great thank you so much
obviously unicef in the humanitarian
work as you said
we never they all all need more support
for
all those types of causes and of course
michelle you broke down what face africa
does
it's incredible and we hope that both of
them receive
the most money possible and uh we
appreciate
all that uh all that they do so for you
ladies we'll wish you both
good luck we know you're here to now go
win the chess tournament
and and uh do everything you can so carl
and i will see you on the other side
win or lose and uh have fun
thank you thank you thank you
all right well now they're going to get
set for their games that was fun and
really interesting hearing more about
face africa specifically unicef is a
larger
um more globally known i think charity
hikaru and some people
not obviously it's an amazing charity
and as nico said does does great work
for just general humanitarian efforts
but
really cool to hear michelle talk about
face africa um and yeah
i mean again i think anything i think
anything for um
anything for charity is is always good
though to stress again um i think i
think all the charities that the
participants chose them they're all
amazing i
don't think anyone chose the same same
charity which in and of itself is also
pretty amazing uh when you think about
it they all chose
uh individual charities that's 16
different charities um yep
and it's it's it's great i think it's
very important to give back to the
people who are less fortunate
indeed indeed well apparently we're
going to take one more break as the
ladies now go from our interviews to
logging into
to the live chef server so thank you so
much to scott colliver
uh ryan's connor zorded bobby baron
there were multiple other 100
donations too and many more so thank you
so much to everybody
um every every dime counts and we will
be back in just a moment with the
consolation final
getting underway
figure out tactics off stream um people
i've met so many of you guys through
this experience and i'm really really
grateful for that i mean obviously
getting to learn chess
is the game and have a greater
appreciation for that
has been amazing um
but i think what's been even better is
just sort of
growing our little community um our
our community has grown uh over
double in the past month which is really
really special and exciting so
thank you so much for everyone uh for
for who's new here who may have found me
through this
or has been here forever i i really
really appreciate it um i wasn't ex
expecting this to happen when i started
streaming and specifically when i
started streaming chess
i wasn't sure if anyone would watch and
it turns out everybody
is enjoying chess so today's going to be
a really great match i'm super super
excited
had some training with anna rudolph
yesterday queen anna
um the most wholesome chess coach
on planet earth i would venture to say
um and so this is going to be really
great
uh nico moves very quickly and she has a
very unique
opening so i've been doing a little bit
of studying of that
um however
castlemania that's all i gotta say
castlemania
if you know you know it's a way of life
not a strategy
okay i guess there's nothing to do but
just sit here and wait
also just shout out to nico who has
played so
like thousands of chess games and has
grown
as a player so much um reflected by her
incredible rating increase over this
entire
preparation and tournament bracket it's
been really amazing to watch
so much to learn from you
detachable octopus friday was my
birthday and i took half a day off work
to watch pog champs and watching you win
two matches was the perfect birthday
present oh happy birthday
can't wait for this match you're ready i
hope so
whoo 11 1 1
stream thank you so much for the prime
anna cranling's community is cheering
you on good luck michelle
caples michelle i wish you a fantastic
match let's make it happen i'm with you
oh thank you guys for the hype train
[Music]
someone wants to know what castlemania
means
just have to experience it
[Music]
just going over the move order in my
head we're gonna be playing black pieces
first guys
so hopefully everything we learned with
anna will come into play i feel like
after all of that studying yesterday i
don't even remember the london
oh my god
albert levin you got this michelle let's
do this thank you albert
shout out to albert for playing a game
with me this morning to help me prepare
mkkkm michelle carrey castlemania
let's get hyped guys let's get hyped i'm
ready
i'm bj minton the founder of grip six
when i was 14 my very first job was a
janitor at an elementary school
and i saved up my money and one of the
first things i bought was a wooden
chessboard
from the mall i love chess chess is
challenging chess is thinking ahead it's
planning it's problem solving
it's very similar in manufacturing
because in manufacturing
it's nothing but problems but problems
are what stimulate your brain
problems are the things that actually
push you into creating new things new
technology better products things like
that
at grip6 we make belts wallets and socks
we guarantee them for life
and just like chest they'll be around
forever
rip six has loved being involved with
pogchamps 3.
we we all know that and they're super
excited to see who wears the
championship belt i'm i'm excited i
don't know what's going to happen with
that i can't wait to see
whether that building makes it on stream
and cameras across the world
but either way we want to give you one
more reminder
to go to go.just.com grip6 make sure you
use the pogchamps 20 code before it
expires it expires after today so
if you've been watching you want to get
yourself a belt some socks whatever it
is
go to pogchamps sorry go.just.com
grip6 or grip6.compogchamps use the
promo code
and get 20 off all right decaro
here we go so i asked a question while
you were while you were
talking which was you have the belt
personally right i do it's right here
indeed i i already said
that if ludwig won i was gonna refuse to
send it to him but he was the only
person i wouldn't send it to
um but is there only one for the
champions bracket or is there only the
only one for the championship bracket
that's a good point i think next time
around no matter what the prize is we
should have one for the consolation
bracket as well
agreed agree absolutely population us
um yeah i i came fully decked out in
grip six today i don't want to show my
belt i know you're not into that he
carried me flashing my belt on camera
but i will come on get flexible damn
come on dan there you go right there
grip six sucks okay
we're all we're all ready grip six here
we go time for the games let's do this
for the win yep
game one all right so nico nico said to
me and you off camera i i was talking to
her about the lesson we did
uh meaning melissa mia nico did and she
said she wished she had just admitted to
me then that she was married to the
birds
um but she's been playing tons of other
openings besides the birds here so she's
she she just didn't want to play the
opening i taught her she could have just
told me that
right exactly so i think she's been
varying it she played like the english
yesterday against tubble i think she
played uh was it d4 or g
she had some other setup as well so she
was really mixing it up quite a bit
yeah and jokes aside everyone i did do
lessons with both
nico and michelle so i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna claim to be a mother torn as
anna rudolph feels when she has two
students playing i only did one but
definitely worked with both of these
ladies and they have both performed
incredibly well so it's exciting to see
and look at michelle playing principal
chess striking at the center
exactly so far so good looks like a
french defense um
i like the way that both players have uh
have opened so far i think again
um one thing that's very unusual oh
right on cue i was worried about the
d6 oh it's right back yeah it's right
there again
no no yeah but the thing is you know the
thing with niko is i
i don't know what it is exactly but
unlike any other competitor in the field
she just moves instantly like she just
does not think she just moves instantly
and um and for better or worse i think
especially in blitz that's really really
good but
she does miss things because i think she
gets set on one move or one idea
and does not consider alternatives
well said and yeah it has been a
storyline for sure and of course it's
if nico was ever in future chess events
maybe maybe the coaching would be even
more focused on that because she's done
so many things so well right carl it's
just that right when she's
it's it's when she's had these
opportunities you just want her to take
a breath for a second and consider it so
it was several moves in a row
she had this work idea right exactly
yeah
so i mean one thing that i would say is
i think michelle if michelle can keep
her nerves together and use her time and
not sort of
get flustered by niko's instant moving i
think uh she will she'll do very well
that's really the big key i think
actually for anyone who played against
nico
um was being able to control the tempo
and not get pan
not panic and get flustered when one
should make these moves in like two to
three seconds
and um and so i think that's really
going to be the important thing michelle
can keep her nerves and use
use uh use like five ten seconds every
move um and try to think about ideas or
even 30 seconds
on occasional boost she's in good shape
but if she gets flustered and starts
trying to match the pace of nico
um then i think bad things are going to
happen no i agree with you
because if it becomes a battle of blitz
intuition or just who's faster
nico is nico is the nakamura in the
consolation bracket we'll say that she's
faster than her opponents i don't know
if you've heard of it
my kids showed him a tick tock video of
him the other day
it's pretty fast um yeah so yeah
no she really is and we saw yesterday i
mean i know you were watching
with me and it was i mean nico won
because of her speed on the clock right
it came down to the tiebreaker and she
and she
flagged tubo on time right right exactly
but again also in the first game she
blundered when she tried to make her
instant move and in the second game as
well she made it and
she made an incident which was blunder
but tubo actually hung his queen because
i think he started
getting panicked by the instant moves as
well and um
and so i think that's really the
critical thing no matter who is playing
as nico's remember there are 10 minutes
on the clock now there's a certain
cutoff i would say
if you're playing an opponent who moves
instantly um i would say when you start
getting down like
four if you get around four minutes when
you have to start moving instantly but
or like using two to three seconds but
until you get to that point using five
to ten seconds every move is not a bad
idea
right and we see michelle used a minute
and one second for the chess.com time
logs there on that move rookie eight
which was a good move
um now she's gonna play a little faster
by the way there have been multiple
north of three-digit donations we've
already raised and there's another one
mikey tko that means we've raised 90 000
together remember chess.com is doubling
the match so 30 thousand from the
community is now 60 000 from chess.com
we hope to spend all one hundred
thousand one hundred thousand dollars
um all right rookie 890 c3 is a great
move by nico hickar look at her taking
advantage of the undefended bishop on d6
right so nico is playing a great opening
so far um i think for michelle
i like knight e5 that's a very good move
very good move by uh
by michelle and see this is the problem
nico she's like she
she has this inability to use her time
so she immediately takes
night and doesn't look for alternatives
and that's i think the biggest uh
the biggest issue um in in terms of in
terms of niko's is she
a lot of her intuition is very good but
she just is incapable of stopping and
thinking for like 10 seconds at certain
moments where she did
i think already she could have won this
game at least two or three times yep
and she has more time than she started
with again five seconds increment is on
the clock everyone which means nico
nico is moving on average faster than
five seconds per move that's ikaro's
point and
if she could slow down we had the fork
earlier and this pawn
is just hanging here if she sees it she
could win the pawn it would be
a huge advantage right exactly
that's a good move too though i like
rookie six of course e5 is a very good
move by nico as well
so um yeah let's see let's see what
happens here
um michelle does need to move her bishop
here however she does not move her
bishop here
um bad things will happen yeah we got a
hanging bishop here
one thing i'll say about nico is even
though she plays super fast and all
the you know whatever call it criticism
or advice we're just trying to be
encouraging for her to slow down
is true but one thing she does record if
you look at her for the most part
she tends to focus on her opponent's
clock like she tends to be putting in
effort
and she's kind of stone-faced which i
think allows her to make
up for for some of the time she doesn't
take not everybody is as focused on
their opponent's clock
i.e some of our screaming streamers
talking to you ludwig and tubbo just
kidding love you guys but seriously
right nico is super focused on her
opponent's clock
right agreed but you also do need to be
super focused on the board as well and
that is something that ludwig definitely
does uh
wait what shall we say right anyways so
um she takes now he's not going to win
the pawn
um obviously it is the hard balance of
like a content creator and
a competitor right so teasing ludwig and
tubo aside the truth is we know that
they're there to entertain
you entertain when you play bullet and
blitz it is a hard balance right to make
sure you're working hard on the x's and
o's and
and being fun for your chat ludwig's not
here to entertain lotto was out to win
did you not see how heartbroken it was
after a lot after he lost to sardosh the
dude was like
taking lessons and with hess off stream
for one hour every single day
no longer
well yeah you got the colors wrong danny
of course it's your fault if ludwig
plays with white in the first game and
wins
he probably doesn't lose the second game
with black which is what should have
happened so yes of course it's your
fault
and ludwig is 100 right i thought you
were going to be on my side on that that
was a
all right anyway i'm a content creator
i'm a streamer
i don't know anything about chess you're
the guy who plays chess
i know my fault all right moving on well
we've got bishop f1 played by nico
not not a bad move either i guess she
has this bishop c4 in mind
um yeah i think i think so um now the
question here is for michelle is what
will she do will she move her rook
move the bishop um it's a it's a
difficult situation here because her
rook on aid and the bishop on theater
are not really
well developed here um so she has to
find a way to uh to get the bishop from
the rook into the game
let's listen into her for the first time
and see what her ideas are to solve
those problems
d5 was good not talking too much
look at rook c1 by nico bishop c4
oh my god oh man she's
fast and strong yeah this is a great
great play by her
you know is you can tell how nervous she
is man
yeah i mean i think um i think this is a
big issue here
is that again nico what she's doing is
um
her moves like she might miss wins but
her moves are still good they might not
be the best ones that finish the game
but she is still making moves that that
make a lot of sense and if she plays
like this and doesn't
say blender or rook or a queen um it's
going to be very tough to
to match her it's going to be very very
hard i like queen d7 though
now we'll see whether nico i would say
there's almost
there's almost no chance she'll play
bishop h3 because she's clear
she should be tunneling on bishop c4
right but of course now i see that watch
use 10 seconds to play bishop h3
exactly the first time in the game um
let's see she is slowing down
like she recognizes she got a lead on
the clock and now she
what did she play oh she played a3
strange move subtle uh oh uh oh oh here
comes a diagonal uh-oh
that could spell disaster for nico
everyone
in fact at the very least she recognizes
how dangerous it was and is willing to
compromise her king position to not get
hated
but still that that's a move you're
going to wish you could have back
right right but but f3 is a great move
by nico
yeah let's see what happens that's the
mating idea
i don't know whether you're drinking any
you're ramate and your mug hiccaro but
i've got a mug here too you want to show
everybody your mug
let's compare bugs but the problem is my
my mug the the water is no longer hot so
you can't see me anymore i already left
the building
oh man you had the
car mug earlier i'm sorry i missed it no
no i mean
what i mean danny is it's a mug where
there's a picture on it but if the wa
you know when you when the water is
boiling it shows up when the water cools
off it disappears so i already left it
so i just left the building
that sounds like witchcraft and wizardry
to me i don't know
yeah yeah it's a magic mug base i'm
gonna call
i'm gonna call magic on that um all
right
f3 was played but look okay so
the time advantage that nico is getting
here
yeah so mess it's it's it's yeah it's a
big time advantage for her
the one thing i would say about the
position though is that for michelle
it's actually quite easy to play i feel
like
in terms of what she's trying to do the
bishops are pretty pretty ideally placed
the queen is well played so i think if
she sees the idea to bring the other
rook to the center
her moves are pretty straightforward i
would say here
yeah agreed and and like you said even
though bishop h3 is on the board
there we go she blunders it
she sees the taxi idea the problem is
the queen guards the pawn on f3 now
i think niko we'll see if niko sees rook
takes bishop or will she play bishop c4
i think one of those two moves will be
played here
i just don't know which one um oh
okay she goes bishop e2 that's a huge
opportunity
that's that's also a terrible move and
i'll tell the reason i think it's a
terrible move is because now it stops
queen f3 so there's no there's almost no
way that um
that michelle can blunder it kind of or
right she can just blunder it
he did blow to her bishop on the second
a second to go around
but nico isn't looking for it it seems
like even though niko's playing fast
she seems to be in a defensive state of
mind too the move she's been playing for
a while bishop f1
right as i say that she plays an
aggressive vote right which is a good
move
and now i think that means she sees that
um oh wow okay yeah and now
unfortunately after they trade
now i think nico is almost certainly
gonna spot uh rook takes bishop
oh wow because now it's just very yeah i
mean now now it's now it's impossible
not to see because you see where your
pieces are
so the only chance for michelle here is
to push her d-pawn that's the only
chance she has
um now will she see it
i i kind of think she should see it but
again i think the problem for michelle
is also i suspect she did not to be
she did not expect to be in this
position and so i think she's also very
nervous as well
so you're right i think she's going to
see d3 indeed she has but but
it's more the body language you can tell
just how frustrated she is that
she's
oh oh that's a free rook oh my gosh but
it's still
anyone's game right oh my god my god
ah i agree okay
there's no way she takes the rook right
i don't think she'll see it
oh she still doesn't see it
okay see that this is very dangerous for
both players though because the idea of
rook g2 is
looming here yep like rook g2
too and if michelle doesn't play king of
one she's in big trouble
uh you mean if nico doesn't play king of
one all right niko yeah yeah but still
i mean richie two is very scary here
but michelle's not looking at it if
michelle does not see richie too then i
think nico probably is going to win this
game
yeah i agree um
especially because if again if she
doesn't see rookie 2 nico's position is
becoming the easy one to play she has a
clear plan
push the b pawn because michelle he
doesn't see if rookie two
doesn't have a clear plan right exactly
yeah
okay rookie two not the best move but
not the worst movie either
yeah right now yeah now now she has to
play
i i mean rook a3 maybe it's still
it's kind of hinging on on the edge here
okay king of seven
now don't go rook eight and hang the
rook that would be very bad
it's so funny because it's the
retreating move right you and hess
talk about that a lot as far as
retreating moves being missed that's why
michelle miss bishop takes rook and she
might miss it again if niko plays for
hey
right backwards bishop captures i think
are the hardest
it's the hardest capture to see or even
just general backwards bishop moves
um because it's not really natural and
in the way like knights you can just
it's generally much more
it's much more clearer it's a lot a lot
more straightforward okay e6 is a great
move here
um but yeah i think i think michelle is
just panicked now e7 and it's game over
and and it's even worse because the pawn
on b5 accidentally guards c6 so there's
there's not even a way to stop you
yeah yeah no totally
yeah oh look at nico coming in
moving fast but getting it done yeah
no totally and i think um it's it's
looking
looks like niko's gonna win the game
here
it would take a miracle of astronomical
proportions
um yeah and
you talk about there's not even a way
like in different levels of just
understanding to like mess this up for
white there's no way to stop this and
there's no way to not
just play a bunch of checks after that
if you're niko
right exactly
so yeah i can't think you make the queen
the king moves and now queen e5
and rook h7 should just be pretty easy
the only trick is richie two rick takes
g3 that's the only way here
um for uh for michelle to try and stay
in the game
wow what a finish that would be by the
way if that happens if she sees richie
too
and nico blunders yeah and then king h1
rookie iii is the one mate that exists
the only mate that exists here
um but i think g2 king f1 she will see
and then it's game over
amazing just to show what hiccaro said
there how it's so funny because if
michelle had played richie too
i think there was a chance that white
would have played king h1
which is literally yeah i mean to be
fair it's 50 50 right you could go
either way there
yeah it's 50 50. anything could have
happened
so it's it's obviously ended the way it
was kind of supposed to and that and
then you know nico seemed to have played
better and she won but
that would have been a wild finish yeah
okay um we have game one in the books
for our consolation bracket championship
uh that means michelle
is now in win or go home territory
sending it to a tie break against nico
would be amazing but
she's got her work out for her so don't
go anywhere we will be right back with
game two of the consolation bracket
final
when podcast three presented by grip six
returns
all right
definitely not my best game but that was
really hard
good job nico
oh man
on to the next game
did i miss
oh damn
man
all right i mean honestly guys i feel
like i peaked on
friday and then i just have no idea how
to play chess anymore
after all of that
[Music]
all right now just wait for the next
game
[Music]
okay i believe in myself i believe in
myself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for your support guys
[Music]
and let's do a shout out to our merch
store if you enjoyed
pogchamps 3 presented by grip6 this is
your chance to get some gear at
chefs.com's merch store
commemorative of what an amazing event
this was it's pretty cool i've got a
shirt and a hoodie
they're comfy and cozy you want to go to
chess.com merch store and pick yourself
up some pogchamp swag go ahead and do it
uh maybe your last chance to do so if it
all runs out it is
it is limited in quantity speaking of
last chance this might be your last
chance to play
our pog champs bots not all of them will
stay
on the chest.com server once the event
is over
so i know a lot of people have really
been enjoying beating ludwig
i'm not gonna lie i've enjoyed all the
tweets coming at me every time you do it
but um jokes aside this is your chance
if you want to play the pogchamps and
bots before they disappear
and okay this is our this is your last
chance if you're michelle carrey hicaro
to uh
to make to make all your dreams come
true here what has she got to do in game
two as white
to make it happen yeah so here in game
two i think for michelle she needs to
keep it um very tight sort of
be calm just stick to her opening and
play relatively quickly
for the first like 10 moves and then
just get herself into the game i think
it's
really really important to do that yeah
so kind of like don't lose your head
sort of sort of thing right exactly
still have a chance so
all right well uh game two is about to
start we are over thirty thousand
dollars from the community which means
we're over ninety thousand dollars total
as that is double matched by chess.com
that's awesome news
let's uh let's get over 100 000 soon
here we go
game two
right so here we go so d4 played on move
one okay so i think michelle
she's been playing the london right yep
and she's been all london all right
exactly yeah okay so nego plays g6
okay now the one thing i would say is
with the king's indian it's a little bit
harder sort of to play
play the setup and and it's very
dangerous because also we can go both
ways where there's going to be a knight
bd7 e5 e4
a fork in the center again so i think
this could get very spicy
right away i wonder if nico got some
tips on playing
we know she fian kettles anyway so maybe
not um but i'll be curious to see what
happens in the post-match interviews
because the the king's indian setup as
you said is kind of perfect to play
against the london
right exactly yeah i think it's a great
opening setup um
like knight d7 rookie at e5 i think dog
dog won a game against uh was it
sex row in pog champs so i don't
remember which one um
but now nico goes d5 and i really don't
like d5 here
yeah us a wasted tempo start and
michelle plays queen c2 you often if you
can take a queen's pawn
and your opponent can't take back with
one of these pawns you should do it and
ruin the position so
yeah wow c5 nico getting aggressive
yeah i like the actually you know the
thing that i will say about nico though
is um it seems like it's only situations
where there's like one or two moves
where opponent has a chance to really
get something but immediately when they
when they
sort of don't seize on the opportunity
the game gets very complicated and
they're forced to
think or think i should say think and
use up a lot of time
right um and i think already it's gonna
be hard for michelle here with all the
all the pressure in the in the middle of
the board with all these pawns here
do not um not sort of think for a couple
of minutes and potentially
go wrong because it's just it's not a
common structure either out of london
yes normally in london you want
something very smooth with the pawns on
c3 d4 e3 but the pawn's on c4 here so
um it's going to be interesting to see
what what she does
yeah and this is when you have these
types of pawn traits i mean even super
experienced strong players can
miscalculate make the wrong decision be
left with an isolated pawn so this is
going to be super tricky i do like
knight d2 even though
you know black is still okay as well
she's completing development
um right but nico speaking of which does
the same thing
developing her night exactly yeah
yeah so i mean i think i think in
general terms um
nico's got a great position i mean the
problem for michelle and this is why i
also sometimes don't like the london
opening
is if your opponent does not play a
traditional pawn d5 pawn e6 setup the
ideas are not as clear-cut or
straightforward like here's the bishop
on f4
what is it really threatening it's not
threatening anything on this diagonal
the bishop on d3 as well
is not threatening down towards the king
on on g8 here because they're a bunch of
pawns in the ways so
the ideas are completely different i
think it's very hard to play
play if you're not expecting it i agree
and you and i inadvertently end up
not necessarily london bashing but we
agree so much on those conceptually
especially as coaches that
the problem with the system is if they
get it great but if not a lot of the
pieces are not ideal for
things you would normally principles you
would normally want them focused on and
and here this is better for nico because
you're either going to win the dark
square bishop or i don't think she's
going to miss this fork
when two knights can go there so i think
nico's going to get an advantage yet
again
yeah and this one actually is is
significantly worse in terms of the
texture because the black king is so
safe here
that white doesn't really but i mean to
credit michelle finds bishop e4 which is
actually a great move
uh because the only weaknesses black has
here are on the queen side that's it
nothing else um so
it's very very bishop b4 is a great move
by michelle
yeah agreed i've been healed i've been a
great move
now you'd love to see michelle save this
bishop if she thinks about that although
i mean obviously taking is
natural as well um
yeah it's a tough position tough
position here
even moves like bringing the rooks to
the center would be good
yeah so i mean it's very uh yeah it's
very
it's it's a bad position it's i mean
it's a tough position to play for white
here i mean i think bishop takes knight
in e4
is maybe an idea although
yeah it's just it's a tough position to
play because there's just black's king
is so safe here you have no pieces
towards where the black king is
though i think nico she finds a couple
of good moves here she uses a little bit
of time and plays a couple of good moves
i think she's very likely gonna gonna
win the match right here so now knight
takes us good
um after pawn takes knight i think
knight a5 is the best fight
for nico she connects puts two and two
together because in an earl in their
first game in pog champs three she
played against sardosh
and she found a 1985 idea with the
bishop on b7 i don't know if it hit a
queen on c4 or what it did exactly
but she definitely found an idea to play
knight a5 opening up the diagonal for
the bishop on b7
i remember that was day one and we had
the call on that she she did
find the idea and remember she drew that
game versus the second game versus
sardocian and sardo
of course strongest players in the event
um right
i take set four was a great move now
this is troubling for michelle the fact
that she's taking
time here yeah it ultimately decides to
take the knight first it's an
understandable decision though even
though it's probably going to lose the
pawn
it's it's a good decision um overall
the again the problem here though when
you look at the position
black has no weaknesses there's only the
bishop on c6 and the pawn on c5 nothing
else in the black position is weak at
all
so the fact that niko already won the
first game she's up on the clock it's
just very hard to come up with ideas
to um to attack the black position the
king is safe with those four pawns
queen side like i said only one weakness
pawn on c5 bishop on c6
if nico for example trades the bishop
for the night and takes the pawn in the
center
she has no weaknesses at all and i think
it's going to be very very hard for
michelle to come back
yeah you keep you keep coming back to it
and now i realize i want to add to it
because what carl was saying about the
king not being weak is so huge because
especially for
newer players when you're when you're in
a position that's hard to blunder that
goes a long way and it's really hard for
nico to mess this up with her king being
so safe that's kind of what you're
alluding to right
yeah so it's just one of these
situations where it's very very hard to
play
shout out to fruit snack with the 200
donation huge aspiring insomniac first
of all aren't we all
a hundred dollar donation and then atlas
192 with 100 bucks thank you so much
all right rook ca what a move by nico by
the way wow
yeah i mean a great move bishop takes
knight was maybe a little bit better but
again for nico i think the most
important thing is just don't blunder
any pieces if you don't blunder a bishop
here
um like i said i think the position is
gonna gonna simplify and the bishop on
g7 is gonna be better than night now one
thing that
i actually did not like was there were
there were a couple of people who really
tried to reinforce this notion
um for for some of the some of the
students that were teaching that bishops
are better than the knights
and um you know bishops can be better
than knights when um
when it's more simplified and bishops
have open diagonals but in general terms
i think for players who are new to the
game
um bishops and knights are about equal
they are generally equal it's only at
more advanced levels that
in some cases um bishops are stronger
than knights so
uh for example like this position the
bishop is better than the knights but
you shouldn't always think about that it
just depends on sort of the piece
placement and the open diagonals here
yeah well said it but i i agree i think
it's where advanced players sometimes it
creeps in because at advanced levels we
do talk about bishops being better than
the night but it takes a while right and
the knight has so many other dynamic
tricks to it it's harder to spot tactics
with knights especially beginner levels
so i agree although
as you just said right now where is this
pony going where's this night going
yeah it's night going i was going to say
right now
who's the pawn uh-oh
what's happening if nico sees g2 is
actually bishop cheese is actually a
blunder because you could try
oh i was just testing you you passed
barely
f plus but i mean as long as nico
doesn't blunder here though she's just
up a pawn
and again look at the knight the knight
on d2 it doesn't have any great squares
and this this game unlike the first one
has been picture perfect
um by nico i would say i mean okay she
played d5 that's the only move d6 to d5
that's the only move that i think
i could criticize at all in this entire
game so far yeah only move that i could
criticize
no that's high praise and you're not
you're not kidding i know she has played
this is a other than d65 this is a
master level game here by black
yeah absolutely wow this has been
been great well michelle also down three
minutes so
it's going to take a lot for her to keep
this consolation and her
hog champs dreams alive mm-hmm
yeah it's going to take some time oh no
oh no oh
no ally oh my god
oh man
i do love how oh my god expression on
her face i know i said that yesterday
with levi she didn't smile until the
match was over literally
it was expression oh my god yeah
oh man poor michelle but also very well
played by nico
yeah i mean this has been uh i mean
again what to say nico made one move
that
at maybe above i would say maybe 1800
level probably it's a bad move
but below that it's negligible and every
other move except for that has been
perfect
just really really nothing and nothing i
can say and she is going to be i think
the deserving winner um in the
consolation bracket here in pogchamps 3.
yeah i mean wow i think when we knew it
was a clash of styles
yesterday i think levy and i were
leaning michelle would be getting the
upper hand in those styles and even this
morning when you and i were talking
about
it felt like michelle but but then you
know push came to shove nico has
has really brought her a game in these
last couple matches
yeah i mean i think it's just honestly
it's the fact that she moves fast but
even even when she makes mistakes
generally speaking they are major
mistakes if she doesn't hang a queen
like she did against rubius
or um or against uh uh tubbo
other than those like glaring mistakes
all all of our other moves in these
games have been pretty good like no
no no real errors or inaccuracies so
yeah um i think at the end of the day
when you play like that andrew really
fast your opponent they start feeling
the pressure on the clock too
and i think that's played a huge role in
terms of her uh win at winning
winning this uh winning this winning the
consolation bracket
b takes a5 queen takes a5 just playing
fast
solid chess now she's threatening to win
the night he's also threatening queen d5
for the record which
be a double attack but we'll see how
michelle handles this
yeah this is just brutal just fall apart
with one move
and um if nico plays rick d
dude she's just playing a fantastic game
right now this is
you can't even be upset if you're
michelle you just tip your hat what a
yeah actually you know i think in some
ways that's actually the best kind of
loss you can have
is when your opponent literally does
nothing wrong because that is just like
okay they just played really well and
that's just life
um but yeah what to say just just brutal
brutal
brutal
you're totally right and we've talked
about that a lot the ones that really
haunt you are the ones you know you were
winning the games where your opponent
just kicks your ass you're like well
good stuff right right yeah just come
back try to be better but that's that's
how it goes like you just can't you
can't really be that mad
about it wow yeah
rook d8 michelle is down to three
minutes and down to her
perhaps final moments in pogchamps three
dinner by grip six
welcome everyone to the big show
yeah yeah this has been uh pretty pretty
incredible
eat it up yeah yeah not not much to say
will you go heat up your mug so you can
prove to me the magic
um yeah i can go heat up more water give
me one second that'd be sweet
sorry guys i want i believe in magic and
i want to see it
shout out to all of our subscribers as
well and again the community support
we're over 93 000 total between us
all right all right so what happened uh
nothing nico's just
cleaning up and uh
yeah this is just i mean just rough
let's talk a little bit about how
the cleanest way is for niko to convert
here because i think that makes these
final moments instructional for the
viewers so if you were
coach hikaru here making sure your
students always win when they're winning
what's the fastest way for black to win
this
between d5 and bishop c6 i was going to
say is the cleanest way to win
um if she plays off six
is there a mindset you have when you're
up this much material should even be
just if you don't see queen d5
just do whatever you can to trade or
what would be yeah you could also try to
trade you could also try to trade off
pizzas
um but yeah well now
yeah that would be
she sees that we're just we're walking
out oh my god we're walking yeah
yeah here's nico
blowing through the final game here
absolutely crazy
mrs mate though
wow you know what's funny there higaro
because i believe she just played queen
takes d1 with the right converting
mindset she's like well
i'm just going to trade everything
because i'm up so much she didn't do it
was seeing mate she just did it to get
the pieces off
right yeah
yeah so i mean i i don't see any way for
michelle to come back here
um yeah so uh
now i don't think she'll see on poisson
here probably she'll just push
e3 yeah and that's just yeah game over
well thank you dark
dark sapient there were 250 bucks
awesome
okay wait a second even stalemate
stephen can't save michelle
right exactly yeah yeah stanley does not
help here that's true
and i don't think i don't think nico's
stalemating yeah
yeah very unlikely
multiple ways for mate and one choose
your flavor oh
yeah well that's almost there but now
yeah
yeah yeah okay [ __ ] mate nico still has
not smiled she takes a calm
drink of her juice i don't know what's
in it but
uh get me some of what she's drinking
because that was a grand master level
game
right exactly yeah
i feel like you know one of those
commercials whether like like someone
does something amazing at the bar and
you go i'll have what he's having
that's how i feel right now i'll have
what she's having with what nico just
did
congratulations to nico
you know hey carl to start the event and
share a little more behind the scenes
you you push for nico to get an invite
and you said how much you felt that she
deserved it
because she was streaming chess long ago
and we knew that she would love and
and and probably be a good performer in
the event and here you go she won the
consolation bracket
pretty awesome stuff yeah i mean as i
think i said before
um long before chess blew up she
actually did play some chess on stream i
think it was 20
it was like late 2019 like october
november
um so she was playing chess before it
blew up and uh she really enjoyed the
game even back then so i think it shows
um her experience definitely played
played a big role in terms of winning
the consolation bracket
yep well and of course we'll have them
for interviews so don't go anywhere
michelle carey also deserves a huge
round of applause so when we return
nico and michelle join us for their
final thoughts on their pogchamps 3
presented by grip 6 tournament
we'll be right back
i don't know if you guys can hear it
though no my neighbors aren't
dogs they just have a very loud dog
yeah nico won let's go ale oro for nico
okay wait
um i played that
i guess i just have to take yeah
yeah i'm gonna watch the finals on
[Music]
stream
[Music]
i was so scared for a moment
okay oh somebody made me dab what the
heck and another hand heart
okay dude my bullet rating is so low
right now
i can't believe i tilted 100 points last
night
hey fady how's it going
oh this opening is terrible what am i
doing
[Music]
but it's fine we'll make it work
[Music]
okay so let's go in here play that
also i promise you guys i'm not sad
today i just don't have any makeup on
[Music]
every time i don't have makeup on i get
asked a million times if i'm sad
i'm not sad i just
don't look great i promise you it's fine
here is that i'm gonna go here and here
i mean it's a losing position but
it's also bullet so
maybe my opponent will be
a little bit less bright
why am i down so much time though okay
here here
hmm lame
nico what exactly is in that juice and
can i have some
it is actually a whole foods mandarin
juice
i don't know it's sweeter than regular
orange juice so is that what
was drinking too is it is it what is it
is it
i think he's just drinking black coffee
oh okay
nico seriously what what a day here you
showed up
and you know there was a lot of talk
coming in about the different styles
between you and michelle you're one of
the fastest players in the event
albeit at times we've talked about it
maybe sometimes people feel you play too
fast
right michelle has been has been more
methodical and had this you know
she's obviously worked super hard with
her approach to learn and try to master
the game during the event
but you just came out you played fast
you played well what
what is going on with nico today and and
uh what can you say
um so honestly i was actually really
nervous when i
um was was gonna play against michelle
today because
i actually lost her when we were uh
playing some practice games with the
botezes so i was all like
like she she probably like is gonna
crush me today like blah blah blah
and luckily like i i was just like
i think i played a little slower than i
normally did today because i was
uh you guys told me that she played very
methodically
so i was very i was actually very
nervous the whole time i was playing up
against her because
she seemed like she was really thinking
a lot of her moves through
and um not gonna lie like a lot of her
moves were very tedious like they were
very like
oh my god i can't believe she moved
there and you know
so um i don't know i was just very i was
just very focused today because i was
very nervous
and last night i was losing every chess
game that i was playing on stream so
it was that didn't help either
michelle i know this didn't maybe end
the way you wanted but i hope you don't
mind me saying i don't think it makes
your pog champs
debut any less incredible as far as
where you came over the last few weeks
and what you
what you did was inspiring to watch and
i can't wait to be inspired by whatever
video comes out of it but
take us through what's going through
your head like we said i know i know
this wasn't the ending you you maybe
wanted but um how are you feeling right
now and what are your what are your
final thoughts
oh my god nico was so amazing it was so
crazy i feel like
i spent so many hours trying to figure
out how to attack the bird
opening yesterday because that's what it
seemed to be played and then she comes
out with something completely different
today and i was like what am i even
doing i got i finished my opening and i
feel like i looked up and i was like
this is not what i was expecting right
now and it was so it was so smart it was
so wonderful and it's just
it's like so inspiring to see how
how much you've grown and and
and just to be clear like i i may have
won one game but nico won the enti
like every other game we played together
it was it was one lucky game so
niko's been totally working hard and
it's really inspiring and amazing and
as you guys said yesterday nico was
streaming chess before
it was cool to stream chess so i think
it's just only fitting
that queen nico takes her throne go for
it nico
michelle thanks so much yeah i i really
i really couldn't um
come up with because i haven't been able
to take other lessons with other
people and um i was just really actually
nervous on top of that because
i just couldn't i didn't know what
anyone was playing and i felt like
everyone know
knew i was playing birds opening because
that's the only thing i just knew at the
time
and i i felt like i needed to find a way
to juke
like my opponent so like i try to open
up differently so
so i'm glad i'm happy that worked but
you were very much a very great opponent
thanks michelle i appreciate those nice
words yeah of course and i think it's
just
even more inspiring that you've you were
literally like
moving around the country you changed
apartments you had a literal
like out power outage for several days
and you still showed up so composed and
and played so wonderfully and i think
it's just so inspiring so
i'm just sweating a little bit just a
little bit
picard do you think if nico can switch
from bad openings and when do you think
i have a chance to switch from bad
openings and win chess games
maybe maybe one day danny but nico also
has one other thing you don't have which
is that she knows how to make moves very
quickly with confidence and that's not
something that you possess
you're you're right uh hikari any other
thoughts we have
for our two players here
what's that i said you have any other
questions for our players here
not really i mean i just want to say
like for michelle it was amazing to see
your progression from someone who at the
very start of the event i think you
would only learn the basic rules and
then just grinding and playing every day
and you did win two-year matches here in
the consolation bracket so i thought it
was a great performance then for nico
um i mean even after coming very close
uh
in the group stage uh just to win i
think
win all your matches you won two of them
in in um in the blitz games as well
just amazing amazing nerves and amazing
chess and you just played really well
throughout
so very very well deserved victory thank
you
well and again we we thank both of you
just for being a part of the event and
of course for choosing the charities you
did both
face africa for michelle and unicef for
nico uh and again
um they're both they're both gonna get
get a check because of your ladies
performance here right
you made it all the way to the end and
um just again thank you so much for for
being a part of it congratulations nico
and michelle can't wait to see how the
how the story turns out
thank you so much thanks guys bye thank
you michelle
wow what a fitting ending there that was
a a wild
uh wild ride he car not what i saw
coming but
in the end niko's experience her
intuition
right you know some nerves from michelle
uh and also again
the fact that nico played something that
michelle was maybe not prepared for
you know sometimes when you're prepared
for something and then your opponent
plays different
it's not what they did they did
differently was that great but it also
hurts you psychologically and i feel
like the way michelle talked about that
made me feel like she was really thrown
off more psychologically than she should
have been
yeah definitely i think especially when
you see an opponent play the same
opening
it throws you off that being said um i
feel on one hand perhaps
maybe on a psychological level um she
should have been a little bit more
prepared for something different because
niko really did go outside the box
against tubbo
uh she did not play traditional birds
openings in either game
um so it seems like she already was
starting to branch out
i agree and and in hindsight looking at
it from yesterday you're right she was
already mixing it up and um
that should have maybe been a clue and
either way i think it's just a good
lesson i mean
any as a chess player as any kind of
competing athlete you got to be ready
for
or everyone has a plan until you get
punched right and i think sometimes when
your opponent does something different
it's about gathering yourself mentally
even more than it is with the x's and
o's and um
shout out to nico for throwing michelle
off and
taking hope i mean i mean she deserved
to win it's just that for sure she
played
she played the best shots today so very
very well deserved
well we we have a championship bracket
coming up but before we do another shout
out to a gaia ki or yerba mate
they are celebrating 25 years you know
it get your emotes out spam it subscribe
if you got some prime
throw it our way it's free anyway it
doesn't cost you anything and now you
might win a whole bunch of cases of
yerba mate
because of it so celebrate 25 years of
everyone's favorite regenerative
beverage with us by spamming your emotes
and don't go anywhere hey carl when i
preview and then dive
in to the championship of pogchamps 3
presented by grip 6
in just a few minutes
this bishop is really annoying
[Music]
maybe i can just like go for the king
like maybe you just won't notice
this is fine this is not fine
you can take that or you can just play
this too
wow what a genius
okay i think you noticed yeah i think he
noticed oops
i thought i could farm the dude but he
actually wasn't that bad
um okay i kind of screwed up my castle i
screwed up my pawn structure so now that
i already have it screwed up why not
screw it up even more
[Music]
ah let's just go here he's gonna play
this or not
i mean it's a very scuffed rouser it
could be worse honestly
face just gift to the tier one sub
tonight thank you for the gift what's up
thank you
okay um
[Music]
why am i not just winning today
okay so if i go
here he has to play that then i can go
here i mean he just retreats his rook i
this is real bad i don't like this
okay oh thank you newport
mad for the pizza the tier ones
and michelle still reacted so well she
has there reacted so well and it was a
tough
defensive position but you got your
pieces out lady and then
nico 2 made a mistake um in that one
moment she only made that one blunder
which was also
crazy to see that the previous matches
had more mistakes
in today's final nico was super focused
and
she barely made blunders there was one
or two moments when she went wrong
in every other moment she was spotting
the the opportunities she had
so it was rough in that sense that it it
felt like nico was really
very sharp today and the psychological
side too
um was a tough one especially when the
first game is decided in one's favor and
then you need to make a comeback
and michelle just wanted to play the
potus gambit for the raid we got from
the butter's life channel no
i'm i'm gonna stop those bad jokes
because this is
this is this is always difficult i
i've been there i've done that many
times when i feel
really awful about my own chest because
i know that i could have done better and
it's not about not trying hard enough
it's
so many factors when it comes to
competitive chess
sometimes the stars align and everything
is working amazing
and other times you feel like nothing is
working and
even grandmasters who play all the time
they
their life is to compete at professional
level even grandmasters sometimes i talk
to one of them
um a polish grandmaster who won a
tournament that i played
he won the tournament and he was asked
what did he do differently to the
previous tournament where he came like
bottom last
so imagine someone who's a grandmaster
2700 his name is radoslav voitersex is
one of the top players of poland
he he's winning the tournament where i'm
talking to him and when i'm listening to
this interview as well and he's asked
what's the difference
what what did he do differently to this
event that he
has just won to the previous tournament
where he came like bottom last or he did
very poorly
and he said he had no idea he didn't
know what made the difference because
he had the same routine same knowledge
same preparation and one tournament
turned out really poorly
and the other one he ended up winning
within a short span of time the two
tournaments
one after the other and then grandmaster
and as the consolation bracket champion
is crowned queen nico as michelle said
retakes her throne we get we get set for
who's gonna who's gonna take the belt
home
between rayne wilson and sardo shikara
we pulled up a couple of their big wins
that got them
into this championship match just for
you and i to take a quick look at
and for the community to get your
thoughts on the different players
strengths and weaknesses so
i chose this one right here in acara
where obviously this game got crazy but
sardocia's
feel for the middle game and where to
put his pieces seems
maybe maybe at a higher level than
anyone else in the event and he started
the plan with rook h4
doubling the rooks in 95. take us
through this game and take us through
your thoughts on just what makes sardo
such a good player
well before we get to that danny you
said you wanted to see some magic so i
thought i would show you some action
the magic yes okay so so how does that
work heat turns
colors different i don't know i mean i
because twitch is owned by owned by jeff
and amazon i just went to amazon.com and
they have these mugs where you can get
an image that's put on it and yeah if
you have hot water it comes on you'll
see like a picture or writing or
whatever and then if
it's cold water then there's nothing on
it so i'm not a scientist or anything
like that but i do believe in science
and they come up with some amazing
things
if this were salem you and i would be
having a serious talk as we move toward
the uh you know the fire pit that's what
i'm going to say that this is this
sounds
like tom fullery to me all right so
rookie played by sardosh but your
thoughts on just
uh the frenchman and all that he does
well
right so i thought the way starters
played this game was really really good
um i think in open positions he excels
in terms of the basic concepts of basic
ideas like doubling the rooks here was
really good
he played 95 after that um the one thing
that i that i think that is worth noting
in this game
now it got a lot closer than it should
have even even though stardust won um
was that once he was ahead by the
exchange he tried too hard to tunnel on
this idea of pushing the pawn to f3
now right i'm not sure what the
reasoning behind that was if it's just
like he
he learned something less and it was
like he thought he had to go f3 g4 for
whatever reason
um the thing that was really important
was that in this position
uh he didn't really need to do that he
could have just he could have just gone
for g4 right away here for example
tried to open up the position so it
feels like when he gets to open fishing
he has the aggressive ideas he's very
good but
when he needs to come with like a two or
three step plan he sometimes can tunnel
on the wrong idea and get into trouble
and um
that's the drawback and that's why i was
going to say that when he played against
the games he lost like ludwig the second
game
and the game against benji officially
they were or the match against benji
fishy they were all positions that were
very close there were no
open files it was very much about
maneuvering i guess ludwig ludwig's game
there was really one open file
um but nonetheless they were very closed
positions and i think that that makes a
big difference so
starter seems like the more open the
position is the more aggressive he can
be the better he does
and it makes sense to win this match
rain needs to get positions like he had
against benji
uh sort of the sh this uh slav
schlechter opening where it's very
closed
um or things where he gets very
clear-cut piece development because the
game's against benji that he won
yesterday for example it seemed like the
piece place was pretty straightforward
he had a basic idea and he went with it
um
so i think for rayne he's just got to um
he's got to get positions where he knows
the structure of the pawns and he has
a piece placement where he knows where
like the knights and the bishops go
great breakdown it almost seems like you
said so after after sardosh played super
well here maybe his own obsession with
getting an open position
is what had him obsessed with all the f3
stuff instead of realizing hey you want
material
you can make trades here you could do
other simpler plans even like g4
and like you said rain rain had a good
kind of delivered that heavyweight
punch in the first game i like how levi
said it where he got this good french
but
the truth is other than the
straightforward french in that in that
second game he was clawing his way back
versus benji
and and um i wonder if this match might
come down to
who has the mindset that works better
when it doesn't go their way right
because we know that if both players do
the things that they're good at
maybe you know maybe they can run away
with it but i want to see who handles
the first punch
right who gets punched and doesn't just
fall apart it'll be interesting to see i
mean
to me i think it's pretty clear-cut i've
said it before and i'll say it again i
think if sardosh keeps his nerves under
control
i think he's has very good chances to
win the biggest single weakness sardoch
has that when he gets low on time or he
gets a little bit uncomfortable the
position that he can panic somewhat
um also on top of that um unlike most of
the other players it feels like sardos
has the entire french community behind
him rooting for him
and i think that also has a lot of
pressure like someone like rayne uh
certainly the the entire country of the
united states on twitch is not is not
here like watching him and rooting for
him so it's
it's definitely a little bit different
pretty much just fans of the office or
you know people who don't you know
have a lot to do honestly no you're
right in fact
i wonder sometimes if that obviously it
plays into your emotions when you've got
a million fans behind you but it might
also
play into his nerves right so it'll be
interesting to see well yeah i mean it's
like you know
what what is this saying if i if i have
one million fans i'm one of them or
something i
forget how it goes but but anyway
uh here we go right on cue yeah so um
so so as i was saying like sardo's if
you watch when he does his normal
streams he might have two three thousand
i've noticed during podcamps he's
getting up to like 25 30
30 000 viewers so it really does feel
like everyone's coming out
and um and supporting him yep
oh man well we are gonna have uh quite
quite the battle here we're also gonna
be joined by the players similarly to
how we were
with nico and michelle for them to talk
a little bit about the charities they
chose so can't wait to hear from them on
that
don't go anywhere we're gonna take our
last break before being joined
by the players for the the charity
interviews and then the games will begin
blog champs will be presented by grip 6
when we return
i myself am trying to learn the piano
but i'm super
beginner i'm a super beginner at piano
i wonder if he's he's also really good
at the piano i feel like sardo she's the
type of
person that gets really good at
everything he does because he said
that he gets obsessed he gets obsessed
with things that he likes
and then he just gets good at them
because he's obsessed
oh levi is playing we can be stalking
levy in the meantime
i don't really speak french so i'm just
gonna mute in the meantime until the
games begin oh that's me uh we are
following by the way hello
charles.com we have been watching the
match between nico and michelle because
i've been working with both ladies
with michelle more closely because then
as nico
explained it on previous shows she had
other issues to sort out such as no
power
no clean water no food having to move to
another
state all those life issues basic human
needs that i'm
i'm happy to hear that nico is now in in
a better place and that she has all
those
normal conditions that we take for
granted when
when nico had to face that kind of
challenge
right in the midst of the tournament
that meant that she couldn't take any
coaching sessions for the past
two weeks and i'm so proud of both of
them
nico played extremely sharp and well
today but michelle has been
doing really well in the previous
matches against mr beast and i guess
pokey
and the fact that she has started this
as a challenge a month or so ago
for her serious challenge accepted it's
it's crazy to
to see that it really is possible to go
from zero to hero i've just been showing
her
youtube channel because she has done so
many amazing challenges but most of them
she said are physical challenges she is
a former cyclist michelle
and her challenge accepted features
things like training to be an
fbi agent a firefighter a lifeguard
all sorts of crazy difficult physical
challenges but this was the first mental
challenge and she has come
so far she made it to the finals she
made it to the finals against
participants
that oftentimes had more experience than
her
and this has been a fascinating match i
i know that
as i said i know that michelle will be
frustrated not about the result but that
she will feel like she could
have done better because we all feel bad
when we don't play our best chess and
and michelle knows to play the nose that
she
knows when you know that you know that
you know
that you could have done better that's
the frustrating part i think
that's that's what makes one upset more
rather than the result it's more about
just the fact that
you try your best but you don't feel
like you're actually doing your best
and that's what i was trying to describe
earlier that chess is such a mysterious
game in that sense that
sometimes it really feels like
everything is smooth and easy and the
stars align
and other days you are like what am i
doing
and you're really trying your best both
days but somehow they don't seem to be
the same person the same level of chess
and
your knowledge is the same your
preparation is the same your routine is
the same
and you don't perform the same way
that's how it goes sometimes
so thank you so much for the two months
in advance we are following
um this potential pogchamps four
participants
from gotham chess here with the black
pieces a very very promising participant
for a future edition of pogchamps
here he's trying to get one of these
pawns his king middle
made it all the way to h3 attacking g3
but the white king is guarding it
bishop to g4 is his threat check and
picking up the knight
but that knight could come here and give
a check push the king back will we see
that
knight coming here makes sense because
that puts pressure on this pawn and
blocks the passport
this makes perfect sense too i think
they
oh ooh repetition of moves
the king comes here now so that the
bishop when the bishop goes back then
the pawn would fall bishop g4
ain't a good move here bishop to c6
putting pressure on the e4 pawn as well
i am predicting a very brave draw for
this game and that's
that's my very very brave call here zero
thank you so much for the
16 gifted subs i think it's 16 because
of our sub goal for real we're gonna hit
2000 which is kind of like my bullet
chest rating i'm terrible at bullet
chess and levy constantly makes fun of
it
i really want to be playing in boxing's
for come on we we we can get there with
my bullet skills
boxing's for i certainly should be
considered i certainly should
just like i did not try to lose my queen
in that first game
well we are we are live here with some
it's been fun
playful banter off camera but we're live
now to everyone and
rayne wilson and sardoche we're here to
talk a little bit about the charities
you guys chose and and let the fans know
more about uh what their donations will
be going towards so sorry
let's start with you you chose secure
secure popular if i if i did that right
and it's a foundation that helps
education for kids but talk a little bit
about
what it does and what that organization
means to you and why you chose it
uh they do a lot actually they are not
simply focused on
people are still doing your stuff but
right now the code situation
puts a student in a deep trouble like
some
don't have enough money to actually
pay their studies they can't even pay
their their bill for their house
uh they have to work
on the side to actually uh
survive and it's very hard to actually
be so
uh so isolated uh so
it helps people with monetize people
with uh food it has people
uh having uh somewhere to live to live
and
and they they help people uh just uh
keeping them on
their mental sane uh because it's really
hard to
support the situation as a student in
france right now sorry for my french
from my english don't be sorry at all
man that's awesome and um
and it seems like an amazing
organization
uh rain i know that uh your your you and
your wife
founded this your particular charity uh
laday haiti
and um you talked a little bit about it
earlier but tell the world a little more
about it
and um and all the things you guys are
doing down there
um thank you thanks danny uh sardosh
really nice to meet you was just
chatting and saying hi
and uh listen you know
i want to thank everyone for their
donations i mean i think the chess
community
has been really generous and you never
think like oh these
pimply weirdo nerds would be generous
but
um really have been and supporting
hikaru some of his charity stuff's been
great
chess.com has been a great supporter of
you know
raising money for non-profits so lee day
haiti is
an organization i started with my wife
in rural haiti and we do
uh education arts education and literacy
for at-risk adolescent girls way out in
remote haiti i mean
really far out there we're working with
800 girls in about 11 locations
and we have a mobile computer lab
where you teach reading and writing we
do scholarships
and uh do health care provide food and
um
it's a really awesome organization and
i'm really grateful to to chess.com for
letting me be part of this and and i
mean i've already raised a little bit
and uh hopefully raised some more and uh
uh
thanks so much and so make sure you guys
are watching make sure you're giving
give big you guys because there
chess.com is going to match whatever you
guys put in yeah
and now we're matching double for anyone
who maybe had just tuned in that means
collectively together
we have already raised more than 98 000
and it's been an awesome day so far so
let's keep going let's get over that
six figure mark soon and uh it sounds
amazing sounds like we need to get some
chess
chess memberships too in the hands of
the day haiti as well rain so we'll talk
about this some chess kid memberships
too that sounds
incredible stuff thank you both for
choosing the organizations you did what
were you going to say
first we need to get them uh electricity
and then internet
and then chess.com members obviously
priorities just
right above right above you know some
some other things so
anyway guys seriously thank you so much
we know you both have a chess match to
go play
and uh your your earnings will go toward
great causes so
best of luck to you both and hey caro
and i will see you guys on the other
side
great
all right that was that was uh pretty
funny definitely
definitely clothing and food and
electricity and water come before chess
but maybe maybe chess is fit for that
you know but i was gonna say on the flip
side even if you don't have um you know
electricity or internet one of the great
things about chess is you can buy an
actual just a small pocket chest
chest set or wooden board plast pieces
and um
is one of one of those things that you
don't actually need electricity or
internet to play
resident eight 250 bucks there were
multiple hundred dollar donations guys
we're gonna get there let's get there
let's get to our goals we're on
track and this is super exciting the day
haiti sounds amazing as does secure
populaire
either way uh remember the 15 goes to
the winner
so if if we raise the full amount it
would actually be thirty thousand
dollars um
and uh we've got fifteen thousand seven
and a half percent to the runner-up so
either way these guys have already
done some good work and we'll see we'll
see just how far we can go let's remind
you of all the other charities that were
chosen because every one of these
is getting some money no matter what
even if uh
your particular charity ie as a streamer
or player
um didn't finish in the top of the money
no matter what the
the distribution uh will will make sure
that every single one of these
organizations gets at least
some sort of uh funding from the
community here and from chess.com so
all right hey cara we've we've been
ready for this we've talked it through
it's rainn wilson versus sardoche i
don't even know what to say
i can't wait and uh final thoughts
before our last
break and then come back for the games
yeah i think it's just going to be it's
going to be a really exciting matchup
um i think the one thing is sardoche i i
could tell when they were talking before
he's perceiving reign to be stronger
than um than reigns performance has been
so
i think for sardo she's felt a lot a lot
of the weight feeling like the big favor
i think he perhaps does not feel like
the favor in this match
um even though i think he is a big
favorite um so it could be a lot easier
from psychologically to relax and just
uh focus on playing his best shots
well they were teasing each other and
sardoche was teasing rain about the
stalemate yesterday and
rain saying he didn't mean to but you
know who knows the banter there
well i mean hashtag paid actor
exactly uh but uh should we share any of
the charity idea that rain
asked you to do probably not i okay
this is uh this is this isn't cycuno
stream so uh it is we'll keep our
clothes on and we'll just leave it at
that don't go anywhere everyone
it's the final game final match excuse
me of pogchamps 3 presented by grip6
in just a couple minutes
it's the final game final match excuse
me of pogba champs three presented by
grip six
in just a couple minutes what are those
charities the final game goals oh shoot
oh yeah
i'm serious i'm i was totally not spying
on the actual broadcast we are watching
gotham chess
of course this is d no i'm so looking
forward to the finals between saradosh
and rayne wilson
i've been watching the interview
obviously and their discussion about the
charities they are supporting
what happened what happened here can
someone tell me
this game bullet chess obviously larry
plays
this move gotham chess with the white
pieces
now he tweeted the screen capture of my
stalemate can we tweet this
queen to g7 g7
all right he had like three seconds left
and he wanted to flag his opponent
he wanted to flag his opponent maybe
maybe it makes him feel even better that
he won on time
without the queen imagine imagine
playing the botus gambit
where he has three seconds left on the
clock three seconds left
65 000 people tweeting my name is anand
really nice to meet all 65
000 of you i've been a coach for
pogchamps and you may have seen me on
some of the shows but i'm really looking
forward to
today's watch party here at my channel
and the main show of course
by danny and hikaru this has been such a
fascinating event i've been saying it so
many times on my own streams that pog
champs
is one of my favorite events and i've
been to a few events not to brag
but i have been playing chess my whole
life so i
know how to how it feels from some of
the
some of the most known tournaments i've
been to either as a competitor or later
the last six seven years i spent working
on a lot of chess broadcast such as
commentary
i've been to the chelsea olympiad a bit
to norway chess white kansai
grunges tour world championship
between magnus and fabian or carrion i
was lucky to be hosting it in london
with judith polgar so i think when i
compare those events to pogchamps and i
say that pogchamps is one of my
favorites out of all these events
it's for a reason it's such a different
event
it makes chess more accessible i truly
think that pogchamps
is a door to everybody to enter in the
chess world because
when grandmasters play that's one of of
course the highest level of chess but it
can feel intimidating
to watch a chess broadcast because the
players are so much above
the viewer's level that it's difficult
to understand fully what's going on
and with pogchamps
well and even though i'm not really sure
how rain would feel about being cast as
the sith hicaro this is some pretty good
pretty good fan artwork here right yeah
this is really really nice artwork
um by i who's this one by don laboot
louboutin i think yeah but yeah it's
really really well done you see rain
here you see sardo's you see kevin
border you see um
you see chiyu uh then there's yoda i'm
not quite sure who yoda is exactly but
um there's yoda here too yeah i i the
face has been doctored in some way but
maybe people can let us know either way
that's some pretty good stuff from a guy
who knows fan artwork icaro has his own
subreddit pretty much dedicated to the
memes his fans make but that's pretty
good especially when you look at rain's
hat here he car
the chess wars hat um and uh and it is
it is chess wars and we are ready to
roll i think sardo sent it up his
final prayers to the chess god save your
breath sardosh i've been praying to the
chess gods for years look where it's
gotten me
mm-hmm viva la france that's what that's
all i'm going to say i bet everything on
i just bet everything on sardo so he
better not let me down
okay well um picard have you ever prayed
to the chess guys did they answer your
prayer or not mine is that what happened
um no i mean generally i don't do that i
think the only thing i will say is that
sometimes there are some superstitions i
have you know i think i've noticed
sardosh has al has worn the same shirt
right
yeah he's worn the same shirt during
every match so he does i don't maybe he
just wears the same shirt every day
because
i mean we know there's a certain other
uh french-speaking streamer who does
that so maybe
maybe i mean starters is trying to just
just trying to model after him
but i do think sargeras has worn the
same shirt for every match
we should ask him afterwards especially
if he wins if that's the reason it's
because he's he's uh he's superstitious
well sardoche plays e6 which is i'll
just be honest not a move order reign
and i looked at um for his b3 system
which
um gonna be interesting to see um and
uh rain rain has always liked this b3
idea against the uh sicilian it worked
out
really well even maybe better than
people thought it would against michelle
and and uh in his first game but but it
has its drawings
for charlie charlie too and against
charlie too so
we'll see sardos clearly did some work
kevin bourdee was
talking to me on slack this morning i
think it was a little bit of trash talk
but i'm too thick to get it you know me
carl i don't even you know know what a
lot of things are right anyway
um so be three players here good
what is the idea behind what sardo's
just playing i'm trying to figure out
because
he clearly is expecting b3 in some order
here yeah
so what is sardosh expecting i think the
idea is
d5 and d4 becomes a problem for white
and i and
i don't know that rain will be ready to
deal with that um
anyway i think the idea for black is to
get d5
and d4 in to make bishop b2 feel like
kind of a lost boy over there right but
after bishop b2 d5 pawn takes pawn takes
bishop b5 it's already very tricky so
i'm kind of wondering what they look
like
it's hard for me to believe that sardosh
has not looked at this ahead of time it
was almost impossible
um that they haven't looked at some some
version of this well reigns
taken his time here down to eight
minutes and 30 seconds
and does finally play bishop e2 i do
like that he's thinking it through
because it's not a line we've looked at
but we'll see how he handles it by the
way community
thank you for the donations crushing it
and it's amazing to see where we're
getting
um so far pretty pretty
oh i don't like e5 yeah and that's a
month
go ahead go ahead no you first chipotle
sensei just donated a thousand dollars
oh my geezer snaps
chipotle sensei first of all if there
actually is a chipotle sensei is there a
burrito school
and can i learn how to roll a fat
burrito
that was good laugh no it's not about
that it's just
i was going and it was a completely
different train of thought and then we
started talking about a donor instead of
about the chest
like i was just seeing about the chest
and then someone would go off on a
completely different condition
we talked about this structure and
eventually you know in a lot of
positions it can be very effective
especially if you know
if we use our imagination and get
everything we want but this is
definitely going to be hard
to deal with if black gets d4 and this
pawn becomes weak so
um i think sardosh has definitely won
the opening battle in terms of prep here
i'm not so sure i'll tell you why
because this is kind of turned into an
advanced french in a sense and starters
has only played the sicilian
so the whole structure of where the
pawns are for black on f7 e6 d5
objectively it's very good for black but
stardust does not play the french
so i'm not actually actually so sure
that it's as good as we think it is even
though objectively position is great for
black
okay yeah no i agree and rain takes
there i think it's because he just
wants to get d4 shout out to blake with
the 420
non-auspicious donation really
appreciate it
and even c3 so as much as this is not
the ideal setup i do like that rain is
going for an idea that we talked about
which we
i you know i did advise him this is a
structure you can shoot for
obviously we hoped to have a light
square bishop in some of those positions
which
you know it's not going to be as good
for him but at least he's sticking
through with a plan right
right exactly yeah so this is what i
expected uh rain to do after he played
e5 was trying to get it back into a
sort of advanced front structure the
with the connect four from b2 c3 d4 e5
versus f7 e6 d5 so objectively very good
for black
but starters doesn't play the french so
i really do like this i mean
i do like the start from rain i don't
think it's as bad as we
we we assume it is at a more advanced
level because again at this level
players usually they prepare one opening
so when you think about the sicilian
very rarely does it transpose into a
french structure like
yep um there might be a this is c3
which ludwig had where it can get like
that but otherwise it doesn't generally
turn into them well and you highlighted
that sardoche maybe not a fan of closed
positions so maybe that works out okay
for rain but shout out to brian with a
500
donation and then i-9a jc coy
on youtube with a 300 donation we're
doing it guys
we're we're getting closer to 40 40 000.
honestly if we reach 50 000 and all 100k
comes out of chess.com's pocket i would
be thrilled
it's all coming out of eric's paycheck
our ceo so let's make it and by the way
danny more magic okay back to normal
i am going to research this shenanigans
and get back to you
we'll see if rain could play before no
go ahead
go ahead no i was going back to the
chest i know that's like a twist ending
you didn't see coming i was focused on
the chest
good no i was saying yeah so just just
make sure to
um i mean just just just buy a mug with
your picture on and give it to your wife
can i get that bug at the store at the
hicaro store
uh i don't i don't have this in my merch
yet no ah
you need one a magic mug at the hikaru
store
right all right um so back to the chest
do you think sardis is gonna find bishop
b5 here or not to stop away from
castling
yeah it it okay objectively it is better
for black everyone because of the light
square bishop that
that white does not have this could be
huge and honestly if
if sardosh saw a move like bishop b5
that could be a really big thorn for
rain in this position to stop
castles not sure if he'll find it yeah
if he finds bishop b5
he's in really really good shape but he
plays knight f5 which i like also it's a
good move
good solid move to go bishop e7 and
castle your king
again objectively very very good
position for black and i i would say for
starters the one good thing is even
though it's it's a little bit close
there is an
open file yeah so it's not completely
closed in the way that his games against
ludwig or his games against benji were
so i think he's looking very
good so far well even though you and i
will probably still be doing commentary
over him let's remind
the whole french community he is
streaming and listening to sardosh for
the first time today
um we uh we appreciate the audience
there
way to go coming out and supporting your
boy and um
he is focused
he is very quiet though
place bishop b4 your thoughts on that
move if he's threatening bishop e5 what
a trick
yeah i think it's a completely
reasonable move probably not the best
move but nothing wrong with it at all
very very reasonable and nothing wrong
with a username like turnberg when
they're donating 100 bucks thank you so
much
now i was a3 is a good move by by rain
now i think i'm kind of curious to see
will starters go back to e7 or will they
go to a5
and actually in a way i kind of prefer
a5 i think it's a little bit easier
um to get the bishop to b6 it feels like
the piece placement is pretty good for
black
here yeah and frank quickly plays b4
which is a good move but he still hasn't
developed i think the question will be
who
who kind of coordinates first right does
brain get the night out
and find a plan with a rook on the c
file or does sardosh
get the c file and get some threats
going on on the light squares like the
square c4
is a very good one uh for black
agreed again it's hard to get a knight
to c4 though you can't really get a
knight to c4 so because you can't get a
knight to c4
um i i don't think it's really a
weakness for one
moment oh my god agar we gotta just
shout out because i think the
community's gonna make sure that
chess.com pays that 100k we just got
a one thousand dollar donation from
freeze four two a five hundred dollar
donation from resin eight
two hundred dollars from float along
another hundred bucks from air hodelkin
and a hundred bucks from em copeland
you guys um awesome
it is awesome danny i will say one thing
though i think it's hadouken
not hadoken this is uh twitch okay
thank you you know you have played
street fighter right
oh like right hadouken yeah you kick
i i remember that i could do like down
down a b and then like blanket would go
into a fiery ball and kick ryu in the
face
are you are you talking about dawson or
something i don't know which character
you're talking about but anyway um
all right all right so a5 play this is
actually a big a big head move from
andreas just because he recognizes that
he really doesn't want the pieces to get
cramped on the queen side so playing a5
that's that's a very good move rain
really should just kind of
that's a good move i think in response
he's trying to build on it although if
andrea sees bishop a4
owie yeah bishop a4 is a very good move
um so bishop a4 here is completely fine
black can also trade and move the queen
yeah if he sees bishop before with queen
c4 thank you louis cause
nisky for 100 um
but rook c1 if reign gets rook c1 i mean
the position is still
very tricky and the one thing i'll
observe is sardocia's time
rain was down a minute and a half but we
have seen that completely turn around
yeah exactly yeah so rain is um rain is
doing fine here i think rook c1 is a
pretty good move
if he can get it in um the the issue for
sardo shearer is that
it can't really attack the pawn on b4
here
um maybe you can take and go queen but
white has knight c5 here
yeah and i'm wondering if sardosh's time
taking is him
feeling like he lacks a plan or if he's
just nervous i think he does have
several
kind of good logical moves but maybe
he's worried about about knight to c5
and just doesn't see bishop a4
yeah no it is possible i mean i think
bishop a4 does a lot of queen d3 though
so it's still very much a game
um i don't like you know i have to say
though i feel like it's easier for rain
to play than it is
for sardosh to play here just based on
the placement of the bishops and the
knights
um right so in a way i would rather be
uh i would kind of almost rather be
white here because it feels like black
i mean sardosh is down wow he finds it
though good move yeah
now will he see queen d3 queen c4 will
he see queen c4 here this is actually
the moment of truth
um yeah will he see queen c4 i think
after queen c4
black is quite a bit better um i could
be wrong of course but i feel like queen
c4 is a very strong move here
i'm kind of impressed that it's not that
rain found queen d3 but he played it so
fast
carl i think that that's a good sign for
rayne just that he saw
he saw how dangerous the pin was and is
maintaining a time advantage
real quick we got to keep shouting out
uh low cu zn
500 bucks dan cakes love that 100 bucks
mm armor 100 bucks armor armor wow
i'm okay potts blitz 250 bucks and mr p
pg with 100 bucks
i'm sure you know these names carl
you've raised money for charity more
than anybody
uh maybe anybody on twitch over the last
month to be honest but certainly anyone
in the chess community but these guys
coming through the whole community thank
you everyone
gustavo with 150 bucks just now this is
awesome well i i would actually
uh in terms of someone who's done an
amazing job raising money for charity
i would actually point to sardosh and
the french community streamers who
i think it was at the end of end of last
year i could have my dates wrong but
they raised uh seven million dollars for
unicef i believe it was
if i'm not i think it was unicef maybe
i'm wrong but i think it was unicef
um god but they raised seven million
dollars for charity
um or no it's amnesty amnesty that's
what it was not yes it was amnesty wrong
one
uh yeah so they raised
they raised seven million dollars seven
seven million dude though
um destroying computers just donated
twelve hundred dollars thirty twelve
hundred thirty four dollars and fifty
six cents
wow and uh though um yeah
pick or you're lying pick what you're
lying 150 bucks
um i went to the school for kids who
don't read good so apologies if i can't
just you know pronounce your name
correctly on camera icaro take us
through what's going to happen here
rayne
i don't think saw queen c4 as evidenced
by the fact that he's
he's really taking his time here what
does white need to do
this is a really tricky moment but
there's only one move which is trading
queens right because
and then you've got to find nice by way
492. i'm actually not sure which one's
better both are playable i think but i
don't know why he's thinking here now
one thing that i would say especially in
rapid chess and blitz chess
is if you're in a situation where
there's only one move you just play the
move
yeah um and then you think on the next
turn but you don't spend your time now
thinking before you play the move you
sort of
there's only one option you always just
play it immediately and then you think
on the next turn
in a slow game you can do it the other
way but um but in a rapid game or blitz
game that's generally the correct
process
yeah no you're right especially from a
practical point of view it just
no matter what why take that time
because you can't anticipate future
critical moments where you need that
time
so i agree this is a nervous moment for
rayne wilson where he's
he's he's nearing two minutes taken on
the clock and still hasn't played
the only move oh oh he plays knight c5
it's still
it's it's a good move it's still a move
though he can play the other order i
would have traded them on knight c5 he
can still do it this way too though
okay no you're right it's not a blunder
and nell or dosh with three and a half
minutes happy 100 bucks one great
buffalo 500 bucks
bellian 500 bucks tillal t-i-l-a-l
500 bucks and omnipot 250 bucks
you guys are doing it you're going to
make chess.com pay up we're going to
reach that 50 000 marker which means
100k
from chess.com 150 000 total to charity
is what we're on pace for thank you for
helping us get there
wow amazing
that's amazing um the charities are
amazing it's just it's been a great day
so far
and um we're really close i think to
that critical moment
in this first game where something is
going to happen something dramatic is
going to happen
yeah we're going to you mean the e-bell
bar and danny falls out of his chair
okay
i don't think we're gonna have those
kind of bar swings i think both players
are strong enough that
we'll see some mistakes but we're not
gonna see someone hanging a queen for
example i just don't think that's gonna
happen
um in this match they both look so
focused
knight takes d3 so you're good at
evaluating
players look at the time danny look at
the time
all right what look at the time wow
g5 is either a great move or terrible
move i don't know which one
but it does he does recognize that white
needs both of these defenders to hold
and so maybe he's trying to
trick rain but rain isn't tricked in
fact he fires right back what a move g4
yeah g4 is a great move um but the clock
look at the clock
two minutes for sarah dosh
like i said sardosh the one issue as
i've
pointed out is that when he gets low on
time he can get nervous and bad things
can happen
um so that's the one thing that's really
going against him here in this game so
so reign is looking very good also i
would say that i felt like in the end
game
um now it was only ludwig mind you it
was only in the match against ludwig but
we did it it felt like outplay he
outplayed sardosh in the end game
um so there is potentially hope there
for reign as well that he has he has
better opportunities as we get later
into the game
well i was going to ask you before g5
and g4 happen because you're good at
evaluating
whose position is easier to play and
sometimes that's indicative regardless
of who's better
but i think we're seeing that white's
position is just easier and
and sardoch's is about to be under two
minutes
i think i you know one thing i would say
is i think in this case it's a
double-edged sword i think it's easier
for
for like one side on their turn
basically um
it feels like it can swing back and
forth though in this game like the easy
moves like now if starters takes and
goes night before the pressure's back on
rain
yeah nightbeat rate moves right before
this would be
highly problematic for white's position
um my producer can't even keep up with
you guys you're going to get us to 50
50k splat with 500 bucks kessler with
250
uh zidw with 300 cocoa butter 100 bucks
and pinchata with 120
and sardoche with knight to b4 this is a
big moment this could be the game right
here if reign doesn't solve this problem
correctly akaro
absolutely and i'm not surprised that
sardosh found it it was it was a move
that was sort of screaming to be played
and um and now for rain he has to find
which rook square to where to move his
rook
rookie two is actually a great move by
the way fantastic move
so sardo should should look to take
advantage of the a file here even
something like bishop b5
and offering the trade that's one of the
fastest ways to take advantage of
disconnected pieces but he plays knight
c2
is this ray brook
again not so clear though because black
can take and go rook a2 it still
still is unclear i guess this rain
doesn't play rook a4 anyway
play something more straightforward like
rook c1 um
yeah i think rook c1 is probably the the
move that he'll play
i could see wow okay but you said this
is this is actually not as easy as it
looks because of rook a2
right exactly so it remains very much a
game still now sardo sure needs to not
panic and just take the rook
um and i think he will i think he will
take the rook here
but he has to find rook a2 that's the
critical move yeah
um and will he find it
he plays this okay he takes c2 of course
the biggest issue is still on the clock
for sardosh i mean obviously rain
playing well and sardo's playing well
but the clock is the real problem
yeah well but now it kind of goes the
other way i would say actually for
cerritos it becomes a lot easier to play
because you can't move the rook on any
two you got to keep it there to prevent
the bishop from moving
so now you can focus only you can focus
on the other rook and just go for an
idea with the other rook so in a way
it's
it's it's swung back the opposite
direction where for sarah dosh the moves
are a lot easier now
yeah especially if you find some some
plan to get the rook involved like if he
sees rook
c8 and b6 or something to take advantage
of the pin
what you said is really clear and that's
why rain is thinking here although
that's a good move rain recognizes he
needs help
he's going to bring the king in
yeah so i mean rain is looking really
really good at this at this point
um but we'll see what a move by sardosh
trying to win the bishop but rain is
going to be one square in time
yeah king d3 is just in time here again
though i don't think it's
i don't think it's over though i i don't
think it's quite that simple
um well let's let's see what he what he
plays he plays rook b4
okay now will rain play bishop c3 is
also a big question mark
yeah because if he doesn't there's even
like rook b3 check stuff so
mateo with 500 bucks dmac dc
200 we are almost at 48 000
which means we're almost at 150 000
total
wow um you know what i was going to say
about rain one of the reasons that i
thought that sardosh was a favorite is
because i felt like rain has not played
a complete game from start to finish and
it feels like this is the first game
yeah
yeah we're like he didn't get a big
advantage out of the opening but he's
made
subtly good moves like playing playing
this uh a3 b4 knight two b3
playing g4 taking on g5 taking the
bishop on a4 this feels like the first
really complete game that rain has
played in the event so
yeah agreed yeah because some of the
games he won early were partly in due to
you know your opponent blunders or rook
on h8 or or those sort of things but
this is this is definitely
maybe his most complete game and and now
he's got sardoche nearing
under a minute exactly yeah
let's see what sardos does here he takes
on c2
okay let's see what happens okay but now
king b3
and you can trap the rook and go and
bring your knight back
yeah the biggest problem with rook c4 is
it okay brain brings the
sardochi needs to get the rook out of
dodge asap rook a4
right uh oh
okay rain misses king b3
which would have won the rook outright
after knight d2
right agreed yeah so uh this is
i mean again if rain can find knight b3
a5 he is winning here
um if he doesn't find an idea to try to
attack that pawn b7 early though and
black can get the king to like g6 or g5
yeah it starts getting very it starts
getting tricky and already i don't like
f4 because
after king g6 black can play h5 at some
moment yeah wrong side of the board
agreed in fact the worst move here for
rain would be a move like
h4 allowing h5 right
you're totally right if rain focuses on
this side of the board it's the wrong
area and if black strikes with h5 this
this is still
a wild finish right i agree
so that and that's the other thing i
would say is so i would feel like more
at the intermediate level or beginner
level if there's an open file i think
actually having a rook against the
bishop tonight generally is preferable
um because it's a lot easier to just use
the word versus coordinating the bishop
in the night
now seize it and now it gets spicy
this is gonna get super spicy sardosh
might even end up because
at less experienced levels everyone even
though the night and bishop are
objectively better look at what's
happening rain is rain is not
it's it's wait he didn't play what what
whoa whoa whoa
what yeah they're both just missing g4
it's hanging what are they doing
what the g4 is hanging on the board
oh my gosh what is going on here oh man
that was
and now he now he almost is losing the
pieces
i think sardo's just panicked i honestly
think sergio is just panicked there he
saw his clock was getting low and he
just panicked yeah
wow he just missed his winning
opportunity we didn't think we'd see
ivelbar swings like that but now
if right right if reign finds the plan
of getting the knight in then white
should still be winning but he's already
missed it a few times and in fact here
you go again
what i was trying to say is it's so much
harder to coordinate the knight and
bishop for less experienced players than
it is to play with the rook and
we're seeing that here even though
reigns better he's not coordinating the
miners the way
you know a master would obviously yeah
that's the thing it's like because you
think about it it's two for one
yeah and now you don't take the bishop
on e1 it's important just like
water is broke oh my god oh my gosh
if sardoshi had taken the pawn or given
check he might have come back and won
that game you panicked
you know it was like sir dosh i think
it's just too much too much in the way
of nerves he was defending for so long
yeah that when he had the opportunity
just he eventually cracked under the
pressure of the situation
that's what it is dude i was just about
to predict that sardosh would give this
check and that rain would play 92 and
black would play king of three
i would thought that was going to happen
but you know what elsa is going to say
danny
that's the second time sardosi has done
this where he's missed a backwards
knight capture on each one he also did
this in
his game against nico in the first match
of the of the group stage we're in that
second game
he was completely winning and then he
just hung a bishop on each one where
there's knight g3 takes h1
so it's not the first time he's done
this bishop is a good move because i was
just about to say the last chance sword
does is to get a knight in bishop mate
somehow
but i think bishop g3 confirmed
yep yeah i don't see it happening here
yeah not anymore
wow he's gonna get like one i think i
think he'll get rid of one pawn but not
both
um and then just the one pawn is just
one pawn too much
there have been more than a dozen of you
who've donated north of 100
that i haven't shouted out jungle bird i
see the last one so everyone who's
donated
everyone thank you so much i think we're
going to get our goals and
and do it with a game display wow
very tough for sardosh i mean again this
is i think what i would say is his big
problem was he got way too low on time
and when he's gotten low on time he
sometimes steals too much pressure
right we're not outside the realm of
wild stalemates at this point reign
still struggling to coordinate the
knight bishop which is
which is um a normal thing uh
wording the night bishop properly takes
a lot of experience but here reign is
probably overthinking it probably just
needs to get the king involved
yeah so king f4 and king e5 and white is
uh
and white should be winning here
so i think the key here is that yeah
king e5 and it's not stylemate the king
just gets in and you take on e6 and d5
yeah
one square left for black or dosh
unlucky
so let's see let's see um yeah yeah just
knight takes pawn
very rough very rough for um for sara
dosh i mean like
he he he really kept it together but i
think it was just the comb it was the
pressure of being worse on the board
and the pressure of the clock as well
and just it got to him
he just he couldn't keep it together
past a certain point um and it was like
right when he was back it was right when
it
turned around the blunder occurred um
so i yeah you know i think i think it's
just one of those things where
i don't even know how you're supposed to
look at it because he's done this twice
now with the backwards night capture but
maybe there's just some way
to just double double check and see i
don't see where your knight is or
something i'm not i'm not really sure
how he can do it but the fact that it's
not the first time is
is um is a bad sign yeah
yeah well and he he had gotten himself
in a position where the rook was
was flexing on the knight bishop and
rain and we talked about
sardosh missing the opportunity but you
know rain was going backwards
with the pieces and the night and bishop
were not doing what they were supposed
to so
really unfortunate to see sardosh miss
the the night capture and
unless reign pulls uh let's reign pulls
a stalemate here
oh my god when he played 25 for a second
i thought he did
oh man look at the sardoc oh man yeah
well i mean
i mean we all we all knew it was it was
a good job yesterday that's all i'm
gonna say
yeah he's clapping frustrated but
we still have another game to go and i
still believe our prediction of who the
faster of the two
is in terms of sardocia is correct so if
the frenchman can get a dub
in game two and go to a tiebreaker all
bets are off so
don't go anywhere it is the final
regulation game of pogchamps 3 presented
by grip 6 when we return
first the frenchman
they gotta stop bringing in 1500s bro oh
[ __ ]
oh gee oh
uh you know what if that's cool with
them too
um not to say that like i'm complaining
because i was weaker uh just that you
know
it's more exciting when they blunder
more is all as i'm saying it's just a
little more
when people blunder a lot it can be
thrilling
um so
chess.com it uh
seems like our time's coming to an end
here
let me tell you it's been nice it's been
uh
something i'll remember for a while i'll
cherish these moments we have these
three minutes at a time these windows
where i pretend i
don't know you're coming but i know
every time
i plan all of my content even down to
the reactions i'll watch the video
then re-react to it on stream just so i
have the timing down
a little bit better but
although it's the end of pog champs life
will move on
chess a beautiful game that brought us
together for this short
few weeks of time and it'll die
these moments we spent together but the
memories
they won't el doido
other moments i can still only remember
xqc losing in six moves that wasn't even
that spock chambers like
literally a year and a half ago at this
point but
still it was fun and
if there's one thing i want you guys to
take away from this
if there's one thing that at the end of
the day is the most
important lesson to take away from all
of pogchamps
it's that every single month you'll have
a twitch prime that becomes available
look hey
ludwig back at it again ah click on the
subscribe button and if it says
subscribe free grip it and rip it
hey [ __ ] i'm taking 10 days off from
streaming straight up that's a fact 10
days
all right i'm going to drop minimum like
15 000 subs aka
triple what's our dose ever had in his
[ __ ] life sorry more like start okay
i'm sorry actually sorry dosh i hope you
do bring it back
but yeah so just double check boys
double check hey gripping a rip it on
your favorite chess creator
um you know but the boats had sisters
lost like uh 500 600 700 to me in chess
yesterday
give it to them or [ __ ] give it to me
i don't care it's up to you guys it's up
to you guys just make sure to grip and
rip it i'm just hey
i'm not here to give you any content
anymore i'm out of this tournament
just.com [ __ ] me they gave me black
pieces first i deserved white
this is my shield period i don't got to
give content
we're over just succulent professionally
and romantically
i will say i will be coming back to
chess
even though i'm on break the only day
i'm streaming is the uh
the uh what is it twitch rivals event
twitch rivals event i'm in it with let
me tell you
a very secret gm
okay let's just say the game of chess
would be a lot different without him
okay is that does that ring a bell
it would be very different
indeed i would even argue that we are a
bit
[Music]
goaded
[Music]
end it zero seconds
[Music]
introducing the grip six belt the only
belt on the market with the no
gut pinch guarantee the grip 6 is so
light and thin that you'll barely even
notice it's there
it's smooth low profile design makes
this belt the most comfortable belt in
the world
overly confident much you're damn right
because on top of being the most
comfortable belt in the universe
each grip 6 belt comes with our a3 gear
and damn tee
meaning if you don't like any belt for
any reason at any time or in any
condition
you can just contact us and we'll give
you a full refund
and we are back with pogchamps three
presented by grip spicks
grip six excuse me speaking of which
grip6 wants to thank everyone who
watched pogchamps especially those that
signed up for the giveaway
did it you're awesome and you still have
a chance to do it but it's your last
chance
go to go.chess.com grip6 and use code
pogchamps 20
or 20 off belts while it's wool socks
be sure to get their last chest belts
and wallets remaining before they're
gone
because they won't be back not kidding
go do it here we go all right picaro
it's winner go home for sardosh
we know the french faithful will be
cheering him on rain taking a sip of
something that's not sponsored and we're
going to move forward
yeah so i think you know the one thing i
would say about rain is his openings
with black have been very shaky um
against e4
so i'm very curious to see if sardosh is
actually is gonna switch up and play e4
here on move one because for example his
game
um he had a game i think in the group
stage it was a little bit shaky and then
he was completely busted in that game
against charlie
uh in their second game in in the modern
but sardosh actually just plays d4 and
bishop f4 which i'm kind of surprised to
see
um considering the situation like i kind
of would have thought that maybe his
coach
uh like kevin boardy would have been
like okay if you lose the first game
with um
with uh with with uh uh
white i'm sorry what isn't
starters higher rated
yeah shouldn't the higher rated player
have been white in the first game
i don't think i don't think in the
regular one i think i think it's in the
tie break
what oh it's not based on rating
oh it's not based on oh okay it's not
based on reading okay all right okay
okay i just i think we said i just like
wait a second it's 14 40
panic attack i know you're watching go
get a life ludwig
stop watching chess.com
yeah sorry i was just like i was just
like it just took me like wait a second
something seems wrong about this but
okay all right um
i agree with you i'm surprised he didn't
play e4
um because again i feel like one thing
that's really important is when you
think the players are evenly matched in
a must win game
i think based on rain playing d6 every
every game
um if sorry i should play d4 and e4 you
could have gotten a very good position
with the same kind of opening setup or
something very similar to what charlie
did
against rayne um as opposed to just just
sticking to a system and it is the final
match so it kind of is
one of those things where you should go
you should go all in so it's kind of
interesting that he didn't
he didn't switch it up but it is
understandable because again you don't
really know
how the first game will go but i think
you should have multiple options
especially the final game of the
of the champions bracket agreed right
and rain has played this
you know he there's no way he was going
to vary up but just to complete the
circle of my
full disclosure what we looked at the
only thing rated i really looked at was
to make sure he wasn't going to get
crushed by the grop
i showed him what to do against the grub
and that was it otherwise i was like
otherwise you got to play your modern
and i reminded him
don't fall for the same trap you did
against charlie but other than that it
was like hey man do your thing
and reigns approach in general uh oh
double fee and kettle sometimes that can
get him in trouble but
reigns approach in general is he just
kind of wants to get to the middle game
he's not into the opening stuff so
that's why
most of my opening advice is how not to
lose
um
he's going to play the hippopotamus with
e6 and 97.97 oh wow
[Laughter]
this is the thing rain loves but this is
gonna this could get him in big trouble
and i think this might have been what
kevin was coaching sardoshan like look
if he gives you the center take it and
don't apologize
yeah exactly so um
yeah i mean pretty pretty balanced
position white has much more space in
the center of the board it's very hard
to play here
um for both sides i feel like because
neither side really has a clear break
um black can't play e5 like black
normally does uh
f5 is probably too dubious because of
knight g5 so it's going to be
interesting to see
um how rain how rain reacts here it's
also going to be really important that
sardosh keeps it together though he's
really got to stay focused
um and i think not fall too far behind
on the clock so i think the clock is
really what hurt him the most in the
first game
yep um
plays nice c6 which is a struggle i
think one of the things rain is worried
about
is this idea of of bishop h6 with h4h5
understandably so it's certainly an idea
but my guess is the reason he played
knight c6 is because he's about to play
queen d7
and i'm gonna try to castle long if i'm
just reading into reigns
brain um although isn't e5 kind of
strong here for black
yeah e5 would be great
yeah queenie through is not not a great
move um by sardosh
but clearly we know who the coaches are
yeah well
only i i just knew because rain really
hates this idea and the moment it was
set up and he played knight c6 i was
just reading it that rain
rain has made up his mind that this is
his plan he's probably not even looking
for e5 but i am looking for donors
blunder wonder 251 and float along with
his second
200 donation thank you everyone
right now sardo she needs to be careful
that if frank castles queen side he does
not play b4 and blunder e5
this is actually very important here
yeah because rain will find it then
yeah for sure for sure yeah i think rain
is not i always wonder if you won't find
it here
but you slow it down so maybe you're
right maybe he's pausing but i think
i think if e5 happens you're right then
sardoche will really regret
what he did here right
yeah this is i mean it's it's hanging on
an edge already very early in the second
game
so let's let's see let's see um what is
it gonna do
okay well i gotta give a shout out
because we did it i mean
resonate 500 bucks j j sutz 200 bucks
we're about to cross 50 000 which again
we doubled it this morning chess.com
doubled its match to make sure we would
give away all 100k
which means we have given away 150 000
and maybe we'll keep going
awesome awesome
okay so the moment of truth will sardosh
play b4 or not because the e5 is a huge
problem here
um now it's now it's actually game over
black gets the e5 in it's game over
so sorry to move the bishop away let's
show the tactics so it went oh he played
it what car was pointing out is that you
can't even take the pawn on e5
because now not only is this bishop
hanging but because reign is castled
this bishop is hanging so e5 isn't just
a positional break
as hikaru is saying it's it's a tactical
nightmare
for white because of this idea
will he do it i think he will
well i think now he's you've kind of
forced his hand right because
he's already got castled and so
unfortunately for sardo she's
and you can't even deny the trade
because if you move the bishop first
then we take
right yeah and there's also knight takes
d4 with e5 which is also very good
oh yeah now but rain misses it
oh i think i think he's thinking the way
sardocious sardosa is thinking i gotta
check mate black
and rain's like well i'm gonna have to
put my pieces over here and checkmate
white and obviously both sides are just
neglecting
how how problematic the dark squares are
right now
with this uh-huh yeah no it's very true
um if i'm sardosh you gotta move the
bishop here you gotta go bishop g3 or
bishop h6
yeah you can also play b5 here but i i
it's really important that sardosh
moves that bishop
really really important
i mean you can also go b5 here as well
but i think i mean
the one thing i would say though is it's
such a non-standard position and the
fact that
it's not um okay b5 i like now will
rango knight a5
or not is also a big question
mm-hmm um he get away with this i mean
he can but i don't think he'll see it
now if he's already missed it a few
times
yeah i i don't think so either he does
play ninety-five
yep good move because otherwise white
gets upon avalanche with a4a5 whereas
now white pushes the pawn to a4 the
knight is stopping it from going further
up the board
yeah inadvertently kind of critical even
though black
uh meaning rain missed e5 for many moves
it's still a really good
position here for the night um
right so i mean i think okay e5
not the best move but not a bad move
either not a bad move i think if rain
finds knight f5 he's doing very well
knight five is not a logical move here
at all though
um so i really do in a way like e5
because it also gives a much
sort of there's a lot less of an
opportunity for um
for black to find a clear-cut idea to be
much better or winning
outright winning here um and so if rain
doesn't see night of five
knight of five i think is the only move
that's really good here everything else
and i think uh
ooh i don't like f5 at all yeah that's a
although although
i mean h6 and g5 is very scary here
okay yeah i was going to say this is
rain falling through with his plan but
yeah knight f5 was definitely the move
the one thing we'll say about f5 that's
good in addition to h6 and g5 hecarim is
that it it also
over protects this square which is kind
of key right because that was probably
sardosh's next idea was a move like
knight e4
right okay anyway yeah so i think here
white white i mean sorrow should castle
and try to play c5
but the good thing for sardosh is that
this will be a decisive game this is not
a slow game
it's it's very very sharp both kings are
going to end up on opposite sides and
it's you know
all in for sardo's share with castles
and then
yeah kings on opposite sides of the
board and a must-win game is
pretty much what you can ask for right
at least both sides at least you'll have
that chance
um yeah so he's got a castle here
yeah castle even if you're putting a
rook on c1 that allows a fork it doesn't
matter you've got to find a way to blow
open the c
file against the black king right and c5
here doesn't work it's important because
on black just takes and your knight on
c3 is not protected once you recapture
that's why rook c1 is so strong
he plays rook d1 okay okay
it's not a bad move either by the way i
think rook d1 is also a playable move
now the question for rayne
the question for reigns will he play h6
go for g5 or will he
if he doesn't find that plan it's very
hard to play here it's it's
probably losing if you don't see h6 g5
um so let's let's see what rain does
because this is this is very critical
moment i like that sardosh
is has stayed even on the clock very
very important i
i think probably in between games he
spoke to kevin is my guest
and probably kevin told him like you
can't fall way behind yeah you got to
speed up
indeed and knight a4 if he finds that a4
to go with rook d1 to remove that knight
then
then c5 is going to be super scary to
stop so i agree with you this is
critical for rain
whether he finds the right plan yeah i
think h6 g5 is almost the only plan that
i see that makes sense here
you can maybe go king b8 and king a8
again looks very dubious
but other than king b8 i mean an h6
he goes knight b3 braves idea i mean
because the problem is of white castles
it's still you're not actually going to
win the pawn on d4 because takes queen
39 d4 and you run into the logic trick
with queen a8 check
um here it's not checkmate now again i'm
sure i'm sure ludwig has very fond
memories of that
um we all know that ludwig's watching um
but yeah if you castle take and then
take that pawn on d4 there's queen eight
at the end
yeah that would be a huge mistake from
rain if he played knight b3 with the
idea of
of giving up this bishop in fact even
here
now that the queen defends the knight
maybe he played it with some idea of
knight c5 which would have been crazy
skeptical but
possible but yeah i was gonna say no he
needs to just go right back to a5 and
follow mulligan by the way we're calling
it we've also officially crossed fifty
thousand before it was a little early
but we are
crushing it and way to go community
thank you so much
also sorry you know the funny thing is
sergeants is sardo's just panicking and
losing his mind here thinking
blunder but it's actually a great
blunder yeah because it opens the c file
now he doesn't have to push the pawn if
he goes queenie two here
um i think queenie two and white's
probably winning yeah
i don't think he'll find it but the
thing is the rook just scoots over to c1
and there's massive pressure on the file
there's also rook to e1 at some point to
put pressure on the e6 pawn so
he blundered a pawn but if he keeps his
wood about him and just goes very
quietly queen to e2
he's doing extremely well but we had
this what was the
match we had with um where the the
knight and rook were blundered but then
the c5 oh i was commenting with anna
with rubius
and and there was the c file right and
um
you're right this is a pawn that while
it looks good could end up being a
disaster for rain
exactly i mean again i think for sardosh
plays queen e2 great move
as long as sargeras keeps it together
here and he doesn't doesn't panic and
freak out too much
he still is has a very good chance to
win this game
yeah the risk of d5 ray might play d5
but the risk is then the dark squares
are problematic and you've got new
problems
um also you you lock in your bishop on
b7 if you play d5
yeah yeah sourdough just needs to take a
deep deep breath and relax now bishop d3
is very good will he see bishop d3 or
will he go bishop b3 actually both look
good to me
well both i mean bishop b3 threatens
bishop takes bishop d3 officially traps
the knight
even rook a1 as bad as that is compared
to the other two hikaru knight c2 queen
c2 you've got
a7 as a target this is i'm with you that
even though the eval bar
or actually bar also likes white the
point is this is a game that is going to
be
very hard for black especially in rapid
yeah
agreed in fact and now yeah now it's
now it's time reign has to play knight
d5 only move here
um to not be losing on the spot you know
what this game reminds me of danny this
reminds me a lot of the game between
pokeman and rubius
um where that was the game yeah that was
the pokemon had bishop on f4 and she got
like a rook on c1 and there was a ton of
pressure
because the king was on scene and there
was that diagonal towards b8 so that
that's what this game reminds me a lot
of
to annoyed with 250 and again we are at
50
400. awesome possum um
i don't know what round this is okay he
finds knight d5 which is
probably the best way to defend e6 right
to be fair
again i i think starters is very much in
the game he just needs to stay calm
and and look look for tactics too like
sardo as i've said before
he's done a lot of puzzles i think he
has like a tactics rating of about 2
000. but based on that he just needs to
stay focused and
keep looking for uh for puzzles here
looking for the puzzle solution i should
say 2000 puzzles is legit
yeah i mean i think again everybody it's
easier when you do puzzling that's one
of the things about chess that's really
rough is when
when you do the puzzle and you know
there's some kind of solution a sequence
of a couple moves that's really really
good
it becomes a lot easier to see versus in
real time when you're playing gaming
you're not being told
well there's a sequence of moves that's
winning the game um
that applies at all levels act it's not
just something that applies at the
at the absolute top um but it but or
yeah um it's one of those things at all
levels people people make those mistakes
takes with the bishop which i guess is
the one way this could backfire for
sardosi is if somehow he keeps trading
and doesn't do what you want if you're a
sardosh fan you want you want both
in fact even that move it's kind of a
wasted check maybe you want these rooks
on these two squares here
um again it's anyone's game though i
feel like i feel like the the
the uh the weakness of the black king
here gives sardosh good chances
regardless
even though even though objectively it
was a bad move uh oh he's got rook c6
he's got rook c6 okay rook c66 huge
music c6
well he also cuts off the queen from b5
by the way which is officially a threat
for black
yeah rook c6 is a huge move will he find
it
if he finds rick i think he's gonna win
this game
what a move and now the only move for
reign is knight c4 to guard the pawn but
then 92 removes the knight i
i think sardosh is going to win the game
now yeah i think it's very likely he
wins
and the thing we'll applaud too is that
he got this position with
time on the clock and the last game if
you missed it everyone
it was the opposite rain had more than
six minutes when sardosh was down to two
so this is a great turnaround for the
french faithful
right now will he find 92 is the
question i think he will
because now i think he can tunnel on the
pawn on d6 and try to remove that knight
which defends the pawn
i would actually be very surprised if
sardos does not find knight d2 here
agreed knight d2 is the move and it
is removal of the defender kind of stuff
he's 2 000 on tactics trainer
i think he'll find him even if he
doesn't find it the next move with a
move like rook a1 or
i mean you don't want to miss it but i
think that i think that he
will see this idea and it's hard for
rayne to defend this pawn in one move
anyway
right i agree well the thing is if rayne
gets moving can go rook c8
all the pressure on the pawn vanishes in
in one move so that's why it's
super critical for starters to play
knight t2 here and the reason that i
think he'll play it is because there are
no other moves that really makes sense
you can't move your rook on c6 your
bishop on f4 is perfectly placed towards
the pawn
um if you move your rook to e1 black
just plays rook e8 so
it doesn't feel like there are any other
pieces really you can focus on
maybe you can look at the queen and try
to move the queen but it's just when you
look at the placement you know you can't
remove the rook or the bishop and you
can tell that pawn is really weak if you
move
it so i think if you focus on and think
about every single piece of piece on the
board you should be able to find the
night move
yeah and again great breakdown of the
thought process which i think
you know in a lot of these pog champs
you do a good job of and uh okay he
doesn't unfortunately fall short but it
was not
not a bad move though they're still yeah
because it also it's the same idea it
threatens rook takes c4
right right yup yup
sorry about that no it's all good and i
think i think rain probably we'll see
what
what he does here but i think it's it's
very tricky very very tricky position
we've got more than 30 000 live viewers
watching on youtube shout out to you
guys over there we don't reach that very
often and
76 000 of you on twitch and many others
across
this is it well sardo's play rook takes
he does nice
i think we're gonna i think we're headed
to overtime oh what is that oh no
what is that by rain yeah oh well now
rain just loses rick takes rook and you
just
oh and now you resigned now you just
resign
so this was super tough for it was super
tough for raymond because of how sardoch
played it i mean honestly he kept the
pressure
rook c1 wasn't as good as knight d2 but
in hindsight the idea was just as strong
and and he's going to take this wow
yeah you know i was going to say that um
a lot of credit goes to sergio she kept
it together like you could tell he was
really frustrated when he hung that pawn
on c4
um there are a lot of movements and
gesticulations and all those other
things
but he kept it together and he didn't
completely lose it and he still made
moves
logical moves didn't spend too much time
um and he's gonna he's gonna win this
game now i think
well we called it then we said that's
going to be a pawn that he's happy he's
gone look at the c
file it's winning in the game and the
other thing is reigns so passive there
there are no background checkmates
there's nothing you can do on the queen
side just the texture of the pawn the
rook and the bishop all of white's
pieces are very harmonious
here relative to black's pieces so i do
think sarah dosh is going to win this
game yeah
it would be very hard to mess up i don't
even know how rain activates here i mean
i guess you can play bishop e7 but if
knight f7 comes in the pawn falls anyway
so
yeah yeah it's looking uh it's looking
great
i think we're right gambit the shrewd
gambit
i mean there are a lot of gamuts that
have been invented on twitch so um
why not
yeah did dwight schrute play chess in
the office i don't know there was
probably an episode with chess who knows
and will they go rook d6 now yeah
i guess rook d6 queen c7 rook d8 is not
so obvious to spot
yeah but i guess you can take and also
play rook b6 there are multiple
solutions if sardo sees rook takes pawn
yeah rook d6 queen c7 rook d8 everyone
as cecaro said wins the queen but if you
don't play rook d8 you play some other
random move
turns around because you can lose your
own f4 bishop
right
but the thing is you can also play rook
takes b6 check as well so factor
multiple solutions
gives him more room um if he takes palm
to work to find it
whereas if there's only one solution it
can be i mean you're really hanging on
pins and needles um as far as whether
they'll find the move um but but in a
situation like this where there's
multiple solutions afterward takes pawn
i do think he'll win but
look at sardos she is actually kind of
panicking again he's not uh he's not
playing work takes pawn he's using a lot
of time here
yep so let's see will he find it or not
this is a big question
minute 30 is chicken
yeah yeah i mean if he gets under a buck
i mean it's it
could get really tricky
listening listening to the nervous
frenchman right now
yeah as i said nerves nerves are what
matt if he keeps the nerves and just
takes that pawn with the rook
he's
thanks for the bishop i don't like that
okay now rook c7 though now now rook c7
he should finally
stop and kill rook c7 he'll find ray
needed to play king a8 to keep it
confusing
right
now
got nervous there for like a second i
mean if if reigning
i don't know what would have happened
yeah but yeah yeah he's got he's gonna
win now especially because as i said
before it's a bishop
yeah i don't think he's speaking english
or french he's speaking
yeah the good thing is that it's a
bishop it's a it's a bishop so bishop
can only attack on you know the dark
dark colored tiles and therefore
uh there's no chance of of sardoch not
winning here it's like 99.99
guaranteed he will win we're gonna head
to uh to blitz
gonna be blitz over time where i think
sort of has to be the favorite
um i believe there it does matter who
gets
who gets white and i believe sardoch
will get white i think it is decided by
raiding but we'll confirm that so
um wow
yeah there there's just no way because i
as i've noticed if you get a bishop
that's the one
end game where your tricks even even if
even in the consolation bracket if you
end up with like a rook against a bishop
the bishop just does not attack
you can only attack on one color of
squares so it's it's not
it's it's not you just you can't create
threats with a bishop
so there's just no way that sardoce
doesn't win as sir dosh
cleans this up i'll uh i'll clean up
what was a discussion
for the community just so you know the
donations were coming in so fast that
the animation fell behind the bar so
just so you know a lot of the donations
flashing now
that we already shot out and i and i
gave a shout out to you before you were
not being ignored just you guys got way
ahead of the animation
so um so it took a while to catch you up
but again
uh thank you to everyone and i think
we're gonna have overtime so
um right on cue there's on poisson in
the chat you know he's the only
checkmate on b7 yep but the
bar is accurate in real time just so you
know the bar is accurate for donations
just like uh if it takes a frenchman to
not miss on
not win uh miss ambassador right of
course
what he said soccer blue we're headed to
overtime it's arma get it on pog champs
three presented by grip6 style
hicaro and i will be right back
time it's arma get it on pog champs
three presented by grips
thank you for the tank sauce right back
we are heading to a tiebreaker
yes oh friends oh i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna go some braille so that is not
stream reception hello everybody i've
been watching obviously the main clash
for park champs three between rain
wilson and sardosh what a comeback by
sardosh this whole game
was so annoying starting out let's let's
do a bit of recap because
this position it looks like white is
doing fine with the connect four
and this attacked but reign missed his
chance that he could have played e5 he
currently pointed this out
on the cover coming from so i think you
know it i think you know it but just a
reminder that this was a beautiful
tactical motive because after e5
the bishop is hanging and you're
threatening to take here if the bishop
moves
you capture the poem with the pawn and
that's a fork the queen is hanging the
knight is hanging you're winning one of
those pieces
and if white doesn't want to allow this
and tries to take this pawn
you take back with the pawn and now
what happens after the capture the pawn
is now an e5 opening up the d5 meaning
that now
two bishops are hanging the f4 bishop is
hanging because of the pawn
and the d3 bishop is hanging because the
queen and the rook of rain are on the d5
we can also show it from this
perspective i don't know if that helps
or not thank you so much by the way for
the new subscriptions thank you everyone
for being so
supportive today you have been very
generous when it comes to the charity
goal
on the broadcast and also subscribing
here lottery goes
was giving a beautiful prime speech and
then people started subscribing
on my channel thank you so much you
really shouldn't have thunder thank you
so much for the five gifted subs thanks
a lot to everybody you're way too kind
let me show the tactical motte from this
perspective from rayne's perspective
this is how it looked
e5 is an extremely strong move because
of the four
aforementioned reasons bishop and pawn
hanging bishop
moves you take it pawn fork pawn takes
pawn takes both bishops are hanging he
was gonna win a piece
there's not a single move here that
saves the piece
for right another another important hint
that you should aim for something in the
center in a position like this is
because dwight's king is still in the
middle of the board
if your opponent hasn't caused that's a
huge
hint that you need to open up the center
you need to try to
open up these central files because you
want to gain access to that king
and make him pay for not castling make
that king pay for not catholic
so this was an opportunity for reign
that he missed
the pawn being pushed to e5 would have
basically won the game in a way because
of peace up on this level
after winning the first game it would
have been very tough for sardos to try
to make a comeback from a piece down
in a must-win situation thank you so
much ezra's monkey for the five gifted
subs
so many of you are subscribing master
with the prime a flying act with the
prime the fancy jester with the prime
asteroid with the prime
spins of it the prime puffy panda victor
pratt
activity 20 gift itself jesus christ is
not my birthday
i'm just i'm just a tiny chess
creator former chess player current time
broadcaster and streamer for pogchamps
i've been one of the coaches
i haven't coached mr rainwilson nor i
have worked with sardoche but i have
coached the girl squad
i've been working with the four female
participants of park gyms 3
as well as the honorary member of the
girl squad that is rubios
because i'm i was then assigned to
rubio's honorary member of the girl
squad but pokemane
michelle curry nico and code miko have
been
the participants i have had lessons with
and i'm freaking proud of each and every
one of them they may not have made it to
the championship bracket finals
but michelle and nico wrote a clash in
the consolation bracket so two ladies
two two of the girl squad members made
it to the finals in the constellation
bracket and i'm really proud of them
also many of these participants might be
back for pogchamps 4. for instance
rubius wants a rematch against
xqc
and as we get set for the final game
remind everybody of how how we got here
in the championship bracket
our dosh he took down huge fan favorite
the only guy who's played in all three
pog champs xqc
then you know someone who has just as
big of a fan base here especially in
regards to his commitment to chess you
got ludwig he took him down
on the other side you had rain squeaking
by charlie
another guy who played in the first pog
champs and then benji fishy the only guy
who beat sardosh
but it all comes down to this it's a tie
breaker not armageddon style but 5.0
blitz style between these two guys
for winner take all he caro yeah so i
think it's going to be very uh
very exciting i think the slight
favorite is sardosh based on what we saw
in his game against ludwig where he made
some fantastic moves really trust
himself
um in in that final final blitz game
that they played so i think service is a
very slight edge based on that but again
i i think mostly it comes down to the
nerves and who's able to make moves and
not panic and use too much time
at critical moments and we'll see if
either side mixes it up a little bit
right we had the b3 sicilian that
ended up being okay for rain but it
wasn't a great start it
it'll be interesting to see what they do
okay i think sardosh is probably going
to go right back to it with some kind of
improvement from kevin if i had to guess
yeah i would definitely agree with that
all right so here we go
now once again this is 5-0 so it's it's
and the other thing i would say is i
suspect that uh
that sardoch has not played much blitz
because his rating is 1004 whereas rain
is 1385 but but then again rain is 1385
is that based on a significant
significant amount of games or just like
one or two is also it's only based on
one or two in his
in his main account he's about 1150
so okay um he's you know what that's
based on it's based on basically
whatever armageddon
games he's had here in this event um
which he's won every tiebreaker
right that's true yep okay so let's see
okay so bishop e2 well starters go d4 is
a big question mark too
yeah d4 move well i think it's the e457
right there should be seven completely
reasonable so far
i will say i think this this opening is
a little bit favorable to black because
i feel like white's ideas are not
so obvious here if white doesn't play d4
and four's open this diagonal like if
white goes d3 i think blacksmiths are a
little bit easier with like rookie eight
and bish buffet
yeah rookie a bishop of fade blacksmiths
are coming easier now you already see
reign regretting the kind of passive
development there but
i'd say overall the earliest sign for
the sardoche fans is what we're seeing
on the clock which is kind of what we
predicted if it came down to a
tiebreaker
sardoche has been the faster player
yeah so i i think certainly yeah rookie
eight good move by sardosh
um really for rain he ha it hinges
around whether he pushes his pawn to d4
at some point if he does not push his
pawn to d4
or he doesn't see the idea quickly here
especially it's going to be very hard to
play
also when you look at the clock
situation too this is getting this is
getting pretty
pretty dicey already for rain down a
minute on the clock
um especially given there's no
increments so there's no help coming
right this is like a
this is a wild west style affair
especially when you were just playing a
bunch of increment
it's hard to make that adjustment but at
the same time both of these guys have
had tie breakers
and right for sardosh it took a
tiebreaker to get here
you know so um we know that they know
what's in store
right so now will rain finally play d4
the last moment that he can play d4 will
he do it
will he do it if he doesn't starters
goes d4 and you open up the long
diagonal and you excavate the
knight on f3 and the pawn on g2 yeah so
he does go d4
good move now 95 is an interesting idea
but again i think it's all coming down
to the clock i think sardosh is
he's going to win this game because of
time reign has got to speed up
way too early though to say that it's
still 246.
i would say i would say if if rain gets
under one minute on the clock and
starters just has more than two minutes
i think
i mean the odds of starters winning go
up to like 80 90
but i think rain still has two minutes
and 40 seconds that is still a lot of
time
yeah um no it's true and and they're
both good enough if they get a huge
advantage
to probably convert even with limited
time on the clock
i would say yes if someone is up a queen
and they have probably more than 10
seconds
maybe i would say 15 to be be
conservative 15 seconds they'll probably
be able to win the game
um so so the margin i would say is you
need to get that winning position
but clearly winning position with more
than 30 seconds on the clock i think if
you have 30 seconds or less there's too
much panic involved
and anything can happen um but until
then okay now there's knight e4 which is
when
94 is winning for black well well um and
it's a very natural move will he see it
uh okay queen c7 not the best move but a
reasonable move nonetheless
95 has been on the board for a while for
rain but he hasn't seen it yet now it's
more critical than ever
yeah the this if rayne doesn't play 95
here i think he's probably gonna lose
okay he does but he's had two moments
had to find 95 and he found him both
times but
again two minutes on the clock
yeah i mean i think for rain this is
this is really hard to play because the
bishop on b2 is bad
black has the obvious lever with f6 to
remove that knight from e5
um and the queen and bishop also are on
c7 and d6 which are lined up very neatly
here
yeah i want to see if sardis finds f6
here which is a very good yeah f6 or
even c3 first are both really good but i
think f6 is just
kind of you know yeah i don't i don't
want to say obvious but when you just
move the knight it's got to be on his on
his agenda and indeed sardosh finds it
this guy
this guy has just gotten so good over
this last month and he's playing this
blitz game like a boss
yeah it's it's it's really weird it's
like when sardo she doesn't have time to
think when he does
his like mind like start to you know
mess with his confidence he just plays
free-flowing chess
he plays a lot better and i think that's
actually true a lot of people the last
time they had to think and start like
being insecure and worrying about this
or that the the better they play when
they just can't think it's just like
they just move you just play the game
you don't let your brain like
disturb you and and mess up everything
well now reign is really getting down on
the clock and this is probably going to
be
a story not not even just because of the
clock but he's also much worse on the
board so it would take a blunder by
sardosh probably
to give rain chances yeah c3 here is
very strong i think
d3 and knight g5 but oh knight d5 oh no
he blundered
does reigns see it knight is getting low
on time one minute on the clock found it
oh this is his last chance it's gonna
come down to the wire
but now king oh my god
[Music]
all
[Music]
[Music]
now that was brutal
what wow you don't have finishes like
that hey caro king f1
right after getting a after being worse
all game
he gets his first chance with knight
takes d5
is probably winning if he finds king h1
but instead blunders checkmate in one
move
wow that's insane yeah that's crazy
because like you're right rain was worse
the whole game
and i think he had enough time that he
probably would have won the game if he
went king h1
he was still over a minute and
everything collapses the knight is weak
the bishop is weak all of black's pieces
are completely discombobulated nothing
is coordinating at all
um so i think rain would have won if he
won king h1 but he goes to f1 and
blunders the
the amazing 92 checkmate and wow what a
finish for sardosh
wow and it was a storybook finish
for the french streamer who showed up
worked hard went full hafu if we're
talking
uh pogchamps meme lore as far as what
she did in pogchamps too but
sardosh puts together an event for the
ages hicaro and comes all the way to the
final
to take pogchamps three and the belt the
belt by grip6 home exactly
oh my god we're gonna have interviews
with both these guys what a wild finish
to this amazing two weeks don't go
anywhere everyone
sardocian rayne wilson join me and
hikaru and we'll be right back
amazing two weeks don't go anywhere
everyone sardosh and rayne wilson join
me in hikaru
and we'll be right back what a clutch
game this has been go anywhere what
about oh it's
i'm just gonna mute this because i'm
listening to myself hello everybody what
the game this has been
southern death tiebreaker sudden death
blitz game
and this final moment it happened so
quick so let's just slow-mo
let's slow-mo why this is so big
first of all stardust blundered he
blunders it after queen c7 the spawn is
hanging
rain finds it with one minute on the
clock so now the queen is hanging
the knight is hanging white is doing
very well here
sargeras gives a check to mess things up
and he did mess things up really badly
for
rain because rain has two squares for
the king
two squares one is winning the other is
losing chess can be very cruel sometimes
if he had moved the king
to the corner the screen is still
hanging the knight is still hanging and
this bishop could get trapped too so
basically black is in a lost position
he instead unfortunately instinctively
goes the other way
and then steps into this night fork but
more than the queen that's gonna be gone
it's checkmate what a beautiful
checkmate spectacular position
the knight delivering check made the
bishop taking away the g1 square the
rook is guarding the entire e5 the king
has nowhere to go
this was the end of the tiebreaker
sardoche taking home the victory
pogchamp three winner i think even
even if reign had chosen this square to
be fair with
the time situation having only one
minute left on the clock with no
increment this would have been still
quite a difficult job to win
sardoche had three minutes versus one so
i think even if reign haven't made that
blunder that final blunder king f1
yes white's position is winning but
would he have had the time
to actually win him because sardos would
have kept playing obviously and he has
been playing really fast this blitz game
so i think even though objectively this
position is winning and white should be
winning
material right now in this game for
instance
if queen to d6 you can take this knight
on e4
because your knight is safe because now
look at this
bing bang boom
the queen is gone this is one of the
many tactical patterns here this
position
is crazy sharp but it suddenly would
have been falling apart
from black's perspective you cannot
touch this
knight if you take the rook the queen is
now guarding the knight
and again this bishop is safe on h2
either because white could be
threatening to block
it to try to trap it on h2
would have been crazy right but instead
we have this checkmate
what a match what a match reign winning
the first rapid game that sardosh with a
must win
in the second game and overall the
clutch win in the
final blitz game i can't wait for the
interview
it's still us though so i'm not gonna go
back to the official coverage because
it's still up
my name is anna if you haven't met me
i've been one of the coaches for
pogchamps as well i've been working with
the girl squad
thank you so much bottom for for the
diamond membership i really appreciate
you're using my
creator code i was just summing up that
if you guys haven't seen me
i have been one of the coaches for park
gyms i haven't worked with star dosh or
rain but i have worked with the ladies
i've been i've been the coach of the
girl squad if we take a look at
the entire field these beautiful
pictures
i've been working with pokemane with
michelle carrey
with nico and with code miko the four
female participants and
the honorary member of the girl squad
rubios i've had five
students in the field and i'm so proud
of each and every one of them for their
own personal journeys their own personal
growth
some of them had experience prior like
nico
who was one of the first to play chess
on twitch before it was cool to play
chess she already was streaming chess on
her channel
while others have only recently picked
up chess thanks to the queen's gambit
too
thanks to the game of xqc the six move
checkmate
that mr beast was referencing speaking
of which
let me let me go to the clips and show
you there's so many cool clips from this
event if you don't know
how to find absolute treasure you go to
chess.com
you click on videos and then you go down
to the clips part
popular clips do you remember this one
for instance you remember this moment
i saw that clip on youtube where you
checkmated xhqc or whatever
um second one because i saw that clip on
youtube where you
checkmated xhqc or whatever um
yeah we don't even remember his name it
was so brutal
but uh and so now
just you can relive some of the most
hilarious
and we are back with rain wilson and
sardosh who gave us
perhaps the most epic and wild ending
you could ask for in an overtime
tiebreaker
a surprise checkmate but before we get
into that good news for you both
community rally got us over fifty
thousand dollars so matched with a
hundred thousand by chess.com
we have a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars going to charity
and a lot of it was driven on this last
day so amazing
amazing stuff thank you guys and
uh i don't know where to begin with this
sardosh let's dive into the chess here
because as you said off the camera
before we were joined
you didn't even know that knight d2 was
made until you had played it right
i knew i would get a mate in three or
four move bringing my rook
and getting the queen if you will take
my my queen i will
i will get a lead of course right when
he moves the king on the on the right i
knew it was basically over but
when i saw the mate i felt like what did
this just surrender
and it was it's much mates but i don't i
don't
think it's like because my my whole
point was to pin that night to actually
get behind
and it's that way that was my edition
start and they
that backpost knight was supposed to do
something at some point and
he delivers the checkmate so i don't
know man
this is crazy it's amazing
congratulations rayne
we know that you said the sicilian was
tough but you had actually come
you had fought all the way back from a
tough position we know you were getting
down on the clock
but the moment knight 65 happened and
then shakikara were like oh my god if
rain plays king h1
he might go on to win this game because
the queen's under attack
the knights under attack and the bishop
and it all happens so fast here so take
us through your
final moments there obviously it was a
shocking end here with king f1
yeah um and that's what time pressure
will do to you i had one minute he had
three uh i didn't think he had mate
in two or three moves i thought that i
could i didn't really mind his bishop
being down there and i think i had
enough firepower to kind of clog up the
middle and
i had some threats on him but so i just
didn't take that beat to kind of go
where should i move my king but he you
know
before we get into that just hats off
chapeau's off to
sardoche and uh just great play all
around and
and the better the better player won
today and uh
he he just played great and um
um but yeah i just i get in trouble
against the sicilian and that's just
something i'm going to have to
study i uh maybe get a better chess
coach for it
i need a better chess coach carl are you
available
yeah you know i was gonna say one of the
things um that was very difficult was
sort of your setup you played with this
bishop to b2
is that a lot of the positional play
revolves around pushing this pawn to d4
later on
and then opening up the diagonal for
your bishop from b2 to h8 if they if
your opponent knows how to respond
um in the opening so it just seems like
a very tricky kind of opening setup to
play
if you're not familiar with all the
advanced opening ideas
if if i will play my initial setup i
will lose to this uh
chunketto but right before the game
starts we analyzed only one
one response to selenium that was this
opening because
the french staff is just too good at
spying you so
they found the exact opening i needed to
play to actually be comfortable and
once again shout out to kevin body just
an insane stuff i mean
that was a team win actually and i'm so
proud
well well guys obviously we could talk
about the chess for a long time but the
truth is you both just
played an incredible event and it came
down to literally overtime
overtime chess to decide a winner um
last question for you both i'll start
with you rayne just give us your
20 seconds we know we know you played
the event and a big part of it was the
opportunity for charity which was
awesome where the community got us today
but tell us more just about
you know how much you enjoyed playing
the event your your you know how much
you love chess
and you know how was this experience
playing in pogchamps
event sucked chess sucks
france sucks
[Laughter]
no man uh this is a lot of fun man it
was
listen i'm an old i'm an old dude and i
was for a little while on the high
school chess team it wasn't very good
um but to get to dive in and re-examine
the game in a fresh way was a lot of fun
and i'm really excited for the money
that we made
uh for our non-profit sardosh if you
want to donate any of your winnings over
to our charity
you're welcome my friend um and played
some great players along the way had a
great experience
and um thrilled to be a part of it and
just big congratulations to sardosh on
his
victory thanks a lot sardosh uh same
question to you just tell us
your final thoughts on playing in
pogchamps and uh and where
where you're going from here with your
with your chess career
um first of all out of all my esport
career
i played some great league of legends
tournaments i played some great
twitch rewards on many games but out of
everything
that was the win i was the most happy
with like
i i will actually
fade out when i when when this game is
it was too much to under
i never felt something like this this
this
it has been like two months i'm
literally discovering the game and
getting obsessed with it and i play like
maybe 12 hours a day for like two months
so i'm i'm doing for four hours of
puzzle you can
make it like it i i went to 2100
and like i play six hours again every
day just sometimes never get out of my
bed and paying my phone
uh that was something i really was
focused on so i'm so proud i want it and
i know i will chill a bit i will i will
focus on another thing i will pay you a
bit of focus league and stuff like this
but i will never forget chess and play
it's until i get at least two thousand
or sometimes some
i mean who can say i eat to the level
some
some day in my life i think that will be
a really good
life goal and i will definitely and for
it at some point here
and play on the board by the way would
be awesome
yeah i don't think i've ever done
anything for 12 hours a day so that's
pretty incredible and you earned it man
um nicaragua any final thoughts before
our for our
are guys here i i mean i just think it
was it was a great match you both played
well and for for sardosh i mean to see
the hours you put in to see it all pay
off at the end um it's just it's
phenomenal i'm really really happy for
you i think out of all the pogchamps
winners
um you were the one who showed the most
emotion you definitely felt the most
pressure when you were losing games we
saw
we saw how much it affected you how how
much it hurt and then to come back and
win at the end um
and so just to see the emotion the
passion you had for chess it was
incredible and so very well deserved
victory
well thank you guys both so much and
again thank you to the community
who came through in the clutch and got
us over that 150
000 raised marker and the two largest
percentages
going to reign in sardoshes uh charities
respectively but remember all of the
participants get
a percentage to the charities that they
chose which is incredible so
guys what a wild ride thank you so much
for doing this congratulations to you
both congrats sardoche
and uh maybe a future pogchamps and
we'll see you then
bye yeah thanks guys
all right man well that was wild
and uh what a what a pog champs way to
end it with a 92 surprise checkmate on
the board a car
yeah it was i mean it was a great finish
it sort of that game swung back and
forth the whole match swung back and
forth
i think you know when i look at all the
pog champs this one had the most twists
and turns
had the most competitive games and i'm
just all around it was a great event
and really as i said before to see sargo
i should see the emotion see how much
time he put in and just to see the way
um the way that he took it so seriously
and then to come through win that second
game then win the tiebreaker i was just
really really special
yeah he came through remember every i
mean anyone just who did i doubt they
did but
um i bet you've been here the whole time
but remember sardochi did that in
comeback fashion he had to win game two
to send it to overtime
and then come through in those super
critical moments of that final blitz
game so sardosh that the hard work paid
off
and an incredible and deserving
podchamps champion there
hikaru speaking of incredible and
deserving
you're getting a deserved raid you
worked hard today you're about to go
stream on your channel so go to
twitch.tv slash gm hikaru
um man yeah
it's i mean i'm i'll definitely be
talking about the event as well but i
just think in general the whole thing
was
was amazing and it was really fun to
watch i think one of the things
is you don't want to feel like there's a
runaway winner it's guaranteed someone's
going to win
and it felt like anybody could have won
felt like benji he could have won in the
champions
championship bracket um came a little
bit short against rain but i felt like
reign also could have probably won this
let's not forget ludwig who lost in
overtime to sardo he
always went all the way exactly right so
yeah it was just it was a great it was a
great
great
event and um i think all the players uh
they deserve a lot of credit i feel like
they put in a lot of work and
and and um and it's just it was a fun
event really really good probably out of
all three was definitely my favorite
yeah no and it uh certainly reached uh
the records
the records in terms of viewership and
and uh engagement that
say that it was a lot of other people's
favorite too and so a huge thank you to
the community and uh everyone who tuned
in not just
obviously for the charity but just
seeing where chess is going and huge
thank you all of our sponsors again
gaia key cyberpowerpc grip6 who made the
belt apparently
we don't ship to france at chess.com so
i'm just going to keep it
that's that's cool yeah good one good
one danny i'm pretty sure
on the next next flight out of paris
they're gonna be a lot a lot of people
who will be coming forward the french
faithful came through in the uh in the
main chat as well and we know that
sardoche had a massive audience behind
him so
all right well um sometimes we don't
want these things to end but we got to
close so again
huge thank you to the team all of our
moderators who work super hard
uh keeping everyone just having a good
time and all the communities feeling
feeling loved and positive
to the staff our producers are our our
team working hard behind all the
all the scenes that you don't even know
exists um and uh all the all the hard
work that goes into making sure that
things don't go wrong
and the amazing thing that was presented
here the commentators
pod champs we gotta think the coaches in
caru all the coaches that work super
hard there's a lot of time that goes in
with the streamers
to help to help them get here and kevin
bourdee who already sent a message to me
on slack i'm not going to read it until
i'm off air i don't know what he said
but congrats kevin of course with the
guy that you worked super hard with
winning the whole event
and um and hikaru and everyone who helps
make pogchamps possible thank you
let's let's sign off and until pogchamps
4
i'll see you then man absolutely it's
great it's a pleasure danny thank you so
much
bye everyone see you guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
there's
[Music]
rip
[Music]
it's
[Music]
camera
[Music]
so
[Music]
three two one